I keep hearing this song.
And for some reason it sounds like the Royals.
Will never be Royals.
You can call me Queen Bee.
My wife.
Hi, Orca.
Do you hear it here?
There's...
Will never be Royals.
Hold on.
Sounds like V-Tuber, V-GF.
See, you hear it.
Hey, Raya.
No.
Did I make this up?
Maybe I'm gaslighting myself.
Wait.
No, you hear it.
Somebody, you hear it.
I don't...
Here, here!
This sock doesn't do it at all.
I'm the one inserting it.
Oh my gosh.
Guys, I'm sick and I'm sick in the head, okay?
I'm sick and I'm sick in the head.
Don't blame me.
Jeez.
You are making fun of a sick lady.
You're making fun of a sick lady.
Um, I'm a little sick.
I'm a little sick.
I have a bit of a cold, but I'm feeling so much better.
And you would think, um, you're dead?
How do you have a cold?
Um.
you are not living why why and I would like to say don't die well if you die if you die don't become a ghost sucks the afterlife sickness yeah yeah so I'm a little sicky Don't get too close to me.
Don't get too close to me.
Or you'll get sick too.
Look at all the rubber duckies in the pool.
Too late?
Oh, no!
You'll just hear me sniffling and coughing sometimes.
Probably.
I want to get sick too.
Why?
It has been just a minor inconvenience for me.
Sure, man.
So, honestly, it hasn't been so bad.
Just a minor inconvenience.
But, actually, no, I lied.
It's been a major inconvenience.
Because I want to play Metal Gear Solid 3 Delta.
And I can't.
Because I was not feeling good that day.
And I have to wait until Saturday.
Well, I don't have to.
But I chose it.
Because I was like, Oh wait, what have I played on Saturday?
That's so nostalgic for Metal Gear Saturdays.
So, after my meet and greets at Vexpo, I'm going to play.
Why not today?
Uh, I have some meetings.
Actually, I have a meeting tonight.
I have a meeting tomorrow.
So that I can't, I don't want to play all day as much as I want.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, I've been busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
Busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
But...
And I have expo this weekend.
If you're going, I have a maid cafe collab.
So you can go there.
And try my food.
And then I also have a free meet and greet.
Uh, at the Vaiso booth.
I will be there.
One of my super chasks got cancelled because my credit card...
No!
So, okay.
I didn't do a charge back.
Oh, no.
I never checked that.
I don't know.
YouTube does that?
What if you do send a super chas and then you charge back?
Does it work?
I actually have no idea.
Didn't win your meet and greet.
Win?
Wait, was it like a lottery?
I think some smaller streamers got their channels deleted from that recently.
Scary!
Scary, scary!
Minto's meet and greet is...
one of the lottery ones.
I don't know.
I don't think mine had a lottery.
I think it's just first come, first serve.
I think.
I can't believe it's already September.
Happy September!
It's kind of, well, I know summer is over at the end of this month and it's still quite hot.
It's still quite hot.
So I thought, well, we can still do a little bit of a summer summer some some fun time if you guys you know and oh wait I saw someone say about the glasses the duckies have it's kind of like my glasses let me put mine on one
moment please oh my gosh wait I really look like I'm ready for summer now
I look like I'm so ready for summer.
And my outfit is cozy for home, but it could be...
It could be a summer outfit.
I'm wearing a tank top.
You don't wear those.
I...
Wet t-shirt contest.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
I want to build the best water park ever.
Actually, I've been thinking a lot recently.
I was like, man, I don't really want to go to a water park.
But they're kind of disgusting, no?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, rubber ducks look like you're wearing your glasses.
Yeah, I know I saw it somewhere.
Thanks, Daki.
Thank you for the donut.
Yeah, I want to go to a water park, but they're so...
I think I would get COVID-2025.
If I went, I would, I would get mega COVID 2025.
So, yeah, it would be a new strain.
It would, it would fuse with like Ebola or something.
It would just become the world's most powerful disease ever.
plague a million wait I missed so many donuts I'm so sorry put your sunscreen on you're too pale to be outside my eye hey hey hey I used to get bullied for that you know I got used to get bullied for being too pale actually people I don't tan I'm a ghost so you know but one time I went to the beach and it was summer camp I went to the beach and they the kids I was a kid you know I was a wee go a wee wisp and they pushed me on to some sand that was like lighter than the rest of the sand and they were like there you go now you belong they were like stay there where you belong so thanks dr. Cranberry for for making me remember my trauma.
I'm just kidding.
I'm not kidding about the story.
But, you know.
Takizo, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to thank you.
Mega COVID-2025 sounds like a monster car rally.
Does.
But yeah.
So I'm kind of pale.
Sorry.
I'm dead.
What are you...
You think there's blood in these...
In these arms?
I don't think so.
No trauma dumping at the water park.
Yeah, my bad.
Wait, let's set up our water park.
Let's do it.
Oh, where?
We get to name our park!
Hmm...
Do you think a lot of people would come to Shadow Moses?
It sounds like there's a lot of shade and it's kind of...
Nice.
Maybe...
Why are you...
Why are you Dexter's dad?
Thank you so much for the get-thin.
Nature since I went to the water park.
And kind of don't want to.
Watering so many people.
Now I haven't been to a water park in a long time either.
Stucky, thanks for the five get-thin!
Thank you.
Patio Moses.
Probably very cold though.
Yeah, you're right.
That's Alaska.
Shadow Moses is Alaska.
It
was my birthday the other day.
I saved my wish for you to get better.
Okay, well, sir.
Karin, did it.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Double, thanks so much for the fine goodness.
Sunny Moses.
Otakon's wet jeans.
What if it's like...
Your jeans are gonna get wet here.
Wait.
Oh wait, I can't do a winky face.
Don't... Don't wear them.
Summer Moses Island.
Zanzibar... Zanzibar...
Wait, that's kinda cute.
Zanzibar Land.
Luffy Gore, thanks for the vibe, good day!
Okay.
Zanzibar land.
Whoa.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
This game.
Okay, hold on.
One moment, please.
It just went full screen on me for no reason.
I'll read this real quick.
New day, new life.
You quit your hated job and use your last savings to chase a dream.
You bought an old abandoned water park.
Can you restore it to its former glory or will it fail?
Just like it did under its previous owners.
Okay, one moment, please.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Wait, it still says that it's windowed.
And 1440.
Hello?
Gabe?
Wait, one moment, please.
Maybe if I redo it like this.
Okay.
Windowed.
No!
Why is it good?
Uh...
Sorry for the scuff, everybody.
Okay, I fixed it though.
Let me fix me here.
Why is this always happen?
Why does this always happen to me?
Kids are cruel, Minto.
Okay.
Oh.
There we go.
Wait, why is it so it's...
Why is it like that?
Why is it cut off?
How bizarre.
Okay, I don't care.
One moment, please.
I gotta fix you guys too.
Sorry, I'm fixing everything.
Fixy, fix, fix, fix.
I hate when games do that when you're like...
Go to the next screen and they're like, okay, I'm gonna undo all your settings.
How bizarre?
Minto's bizarre water park.
Wow!
Wait, this is like the most random location.
I look like... I look like I'm crazy.
Hello, Dallas.
Oh!
Blanking Minto equals Q.
Oh, thank you for the hotness over!
Do you think he'll come to my park now?
Why me?
Get inside.
Get in...
Oh, use the sledgehammer to clear the entrance.
They could just give me the keys, no?
Whoa!
Okay.
What a mess!
This dusty, broken-down water park has definitely seen some better days.
This is not a water park.
This is a...
pool and he just walks away just tis a flesh wound first let's clear out all the old buildings use your sledgehammer to demolish old buildings I'm insane this is not a water park oh wait you see a slide over there oh what happened What happened to me?
I jumped with too much force.
Initial sledgehammer use...
Was based?
No.
It's a crime.
Minto gets hammer, instant crime.
It's the horny hammer for you all.
Bam!
Requires a trash bag.
Oh, destroy- I'm destroying this?
Still not there.
Not exactly five-star cleanliness, huh?
Trash is everywhere, and let's be real.
No one's lining up to relax next to a pile of old...
Why did I get rid of the pool?
It's my one attraction!
Waterpark sim or insane?
Slashhammerman sim.
Grab a trash bag, clean up the mess, and toss it all by holding right click into the dumpster.
Whoa.
Nobody's gonna come here.
Oh, my gosh.
Destroy!
So I get trash.
Oh, over here.
Okay.
Trash.
I really wanted something kind of...
Oh, throw away the trash.
Oh, is it full?
Okay.
I wanted something kind of chill today since I'm a little, you know, a little icky-sicky, you know.
Use your hands to remove newspapers from the entrance window.
Okay.
Nice throw.
I got a 10 out of 10 for that.
Life ring.
Staff leaderboard.
Oh no, my sledgehammer.
Oh, whoa.
Wow.
Whoa.
Wait.
Why are there so many boxes?
Oh, these here.
Clear.
Wait, whatever.
Use my hands.
Okay, I have those.
Ah!
I use the force.
Building your park.
I didn't have a water park without a pool.
Yeah, we destroyed it for some reason.
Each pool you build raises the number of max guests your park can have.
Press B to open the building menu.
Select a rusty pool.
No, I don't want a rusty pool.
It was a dirty pool.
I didn't have clean nerves.
I need to stream on my birthday, Abby!
Five, six, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Hit it with your hammer a couple times to build it.
Enjoy the first splash.
I love these guys.
We really are twinning!
He's seen better days.
Me too.
Cannonball!
I lived!
Wow.
Okay.
We are building a pool.
Building a pool.
I want to get rid of some of this trash first though.
Okay, hold on.
One moment.
We still have more trash here.
Let's finish cleaning up.
In fact, let's like get rid of everything.
Well, not everything, but you know, like let's make the most space that we can because like get rid of these you know so that we can have the biggest amount of room for our pool those chairs are garbage too I think so oh I can destroy them no way decided to play along with you and glitched outside the for the first few minutes press double space that's what Oh,
I fell!
I see.
How do you glitch outside?
There's a streamer I like.
He was playing this yesterday.
I didn't watch so much of it because I was like, oh, this seems kind of fun.
And then I...
I do want to say another VTuber is playing this at the same time as me.
And it was an absolute coincidence my bad I was like what can I play that's kind of chill today oh streamer I like is playing this I'll play it too oopsie but I think this is like the hot streamer game right now because I think I saw a review on here on steam that like KSO played it so you'll probably see more people end up playing this game
You'll probably see more people end up playing it.
Okay, I think we...
Let me throw away my garbage.
Nice, throw 9 out of 10.
Okay, okay.
Wait, can I see myself?
Oh!
I dominate the first pool.
Ponzi pool!
It's just a summer game of the year or something.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, there's more over here, too.
I like how I'm...
What am I doing?
Whoa.
I'm swimming.
I've become one with the pool.
When you...
When you pool hard enough, life becomes a pool.
You know?
You don't have to worry about anything.
Except drowning, I suppose.
Let's get another look.
I should have stuck with our first.
Why am I so old?
Why did I...
Can I change anything?
Oh no.
This is good enough.
Wait, how do I get out of...
Wait, I don't want to be in third person anymore.
Get me out of here!
No!
How do I get out of third person?
Uh-oh.
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, oh, here we go, oh, so this is the keep out, this all looks fancy, I can take the glove, oh, there's gonna be someone, who's, oh my gosh, people are already camping outside, so excited, oh wait,
look at all these potential customers!
Nikolai!
You've been selected!
Oh, hit visitor with a boxing glove.
Dallas is back!
Okay, anyway.
How do I put this away?
Uh, drop?
Is there a...
Hold on.
Oh, drop item Q.
Flyer.
Oh, that costs money.
Did it say...
Oh, oh, okay.
Flyers are five bucks.
Time adult.
Teen set.
Okay, let me...
Hold on.
Press Bui.
Okay, we are...
We're building a pool, everybody.
Ooh, I got my little drone.
Oh, my gosh.
I want to go everywhere.
Okay.
We're going to build ourselves a rusty pool.
Oh, it's small.
Use the hammer on the placed pool blueprint to build it.
Oh, it's crooked!
It's fine.
Oh, it's like really shallow.
Oh my gosh.
Is the boxing glove special available at the maid cafe?
You want that?
What's this?
Close.
Oh!
Oh gosh!
Okay.
Press B on the building menu and place a diving board.
I don't think...
I don't think that's safe.
Can I move it?
Oh, oh, I can!
Oh my gosh, we can fix it, everybody.
Fix it, Minto.
I don't think a diving board is, like, really easy.
Okay.
How do I place it?
Oh, I place it, like, here.
Is that...
That doesn't seem correct.
Okay.
Make it super high.
From over here, you have to...
You have to jump.
From all the way in the bushes.
I believe in you.
We'll just put it right there.
That seems kind of far away, no?
Did you guys ever...
I used to...
When I did swimming, I would dive from the really, really tall ones.
like the super tall now I don't think I could I would be too scared but as a wee whisp I was fearless does this work it doesn't look like it's close enough no you can't swim I think that's such an important thing though always learn how to swim
Now Minto has wisdom I've got too much to lose Preparations are done Go to the ticket office and open the park With a button on the wall Once you're open for business Start selling those tickets Choose the right time Age and past type Print it out and pass it to your eager guest Oh okay Wait does this work Oh Oh Oh!
I'm gonna drown!
This is why you should learn how to How to swim!
Take the ladder out!
I'm dripping wet!
They'll know that the park works.
Thunder Adelos, thank you so much for the for the 10 gifted.
It was very hydrodynamic.
Wait, how do I turn it on?
Oh.
Bing bong!
Open park!
Wait.
Time?
Add time.
What does that mean?
How do I make the park?
Oh, here!
Whoa!
Okay.
Medkit injector?
Okay, they're gonna be...
They're gonna be scrambling to get in here.
Oh my gosh!
Denver, you're...
Oh, you're a teen?
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, that's the time.
How do I give you a ticket?
Oh, ticket.
There you go.
Young man.
Mariah, you're an adult?
Okay.
Here's your ticket.
Enjoy the pool.
What?
What did I give you?
You gave the wrong ticket.
Adult!
Price 8.
Oh, for 6 hours!
Oh!
Oops.
There you go.
Thanks, Erin.
Why are you in there for...
This for 6 hours?
Ruth, here you go.
Ticket cheaters!
A guest has sneaked into the park without a valid ticket.
You can spot them quite easy.
They're missing a bracelet.
Push them out with right click to send a message.
I just only allowed like two people into my park.
You?
No, you have a wristband.
You have a wristband.
I should have sledgehammered him.
Yes, occasionally leave puddles of water.
Yeah, those dry in the sun.
Grab your trusty mop and clean them up before someone takes a tumble.
Oh, where's...
Kade will learn to follow the law.
Oh, he just said, ow.
Um, what was I doing?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay, uh, the mop is over here.
We gotta avoid the puddles.
Waterpark simulator is shocking and violent.
Stop!
He's already dead!
If you lost, if you drop or lose a tool, don't panic.
Tool shed always keeps them safe.
Okay.
La la.
Who came over here to get a puddle so crazy?
Also, why is our place not, like, slip-proof, you know?
Is this what it's like to really own a water park?
Zach, welcome back.
Thank you.
It sends a message.
I don't know, I can't supply those.
They have to bring them themselves.
Swimming is just the beginning.
Slides are real.
Yes.
Slides are the real stars of the water park.
Yes, yes, yes.
But not everyone's a thrill seeker.
Make sure to check if guests want a slide pass.
A slide pass?
That's not included in the fee to get into the park?
I'm, I'm, I'm squeezing every penny out of these people.
What the heck?
Oh my gosh!
Hellscape.
Offer the wrong ticket and they'll turn around and leave.
Okay.
We don't want that.
Look at their spending money while they're swimming.
Look at them go.
Wow.
I'm watching a human zoo.
Erin's got cake.
Okay, Erin.
Oh, not again!
Oh, Erin!
Erin, family guide pose.
No, don't leave!
Please don't leave.
Please love my park.
Human aquarium.
Erin, don't leave.
Oh, oh.
Go, Ruth, go!
You can do it!
You have to pay to use the diving board!
No way.
Business, minto business.
Energy zero.
Okay, you can leave them.
You can leave.
Why are you paying more money?
Wait, did you not pay to get inside?
What?
Oh wait, I have to build a slide.
Rusty slide.
I forgot.
Oh, this is kind of terrible.
Okay, here we go.
Uh, how do I...
Okay, like, like that.
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Everybody, new attraction.
And three, two, one.
Ta-da!
Epic Universe is now open!
Oh, my gosh.
I've seen endless, and I mean endless videos about Halloween horror nights this year.
the terrifier house and how there's the wet part and the dry part and i've seen everything about the cat lady and i've seen everything about five nights of freddies i've seen so many videos from chill to relief running around a water park is fun but even the most energetic guests need a break set up comfy loungers for relaxation to make sure the toilets are nearby for when nature calls tired or desperate guests won't stay long Or they won't stay clean!
Is that shit in my pool?
No, and trash!
Oh my gosh, we need a bathroom pronto!
Okay, wait.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Here, we'll put it in the shade.
There's only three people, so we'll give them three.
Where's the...
Facilities!
Oh no!
Wait, I can't build a pot yet.
I need to clean up this pool and garbage.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, so sorry.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Take that.
Wait, grab that.
How am I supposed to clean this up?
Oh, I did it with my bare hands.
Okay, Aaron, let's not be dramatic.
Oh, she's asleep.
Okay, that's fine.
One moment.
A four-hour pass for a teen.
There you are, Kade.
What?
What did I do wrong?
Oh, did he want to slide?
Was that my bad?
Oops.
No space.
Oh, I have it already.
Pass, I didn't notice it.
Oopsie!
I'm not gonna make any money.
These people only have two dollars.
New research point.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Aaron!
Damn, Aaron.
Okay.
You didn't wash your hands after cleaning the poop.
I didn't mean to.
They're putting more garbage.
I'm gonna ban these people.
Oh, we need the rusty toilet.
Okay, now we can build it.
Okay.
We'll put it, like, right here.
Right here.
Should be good enough.
They have to pay a dollar to lay down?
I can't believe this.
I am a true entrepreneur.
Why is there so much dirt falling?
I don't...
They go and they, like, roll around in the grass, like, dog.
because they don't have towels.
One more guess.
Oh, the flyers.
Okay.
You just go give it to them.
You just go give them flyers.
Hello.
Take flyer, take flyer, take flyer.
Oh!
Oh.
I don't even need to do anything.
Hello, Jeremiah.
You would like a teen pass for four hours?
You don't want to eat.
use our slide?
Are you sure?
Hello?
Slide pass.
I see it.
Four hours teen.
Okay.
The water looks.
It looks great.
What are you talking about?
Hello.
Hello?
Slide pass.
Adult.
Okay.
Can I see your ID?
I got a baby face.
Ruby.
Senior.
Slide pass.
Damn.
Ruby.
She's living on the wild side.
Grandma.
Okay.
Alright, let's go get some more people.
Uh.
Ew.
Hello?
Here.
Would you like this?
Oh, whoa.
This?
Oh.
Immediate.
Hello.
Would you like to come to my park?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Everyone is peeing in the pool.
Wait, don't they're not?
Wait, are they?
Are they peeing in my pool?
Of the world's...
No.
I can't tell, actually.
Hi, Desko.
The guest is waiting to buy a ticket.
I'm so sorry.
Hello.
Slide pass.
Team for eight hours.
Okay.
A teen.
You're gonna become the most tan person ever.
Oh, yeah, I gave you a teen pass for four hours.
What if I accidentally give them the slide pass, but they're excited?
Would they get excited about it, you think?
That's some stamina.
That's what I'm saying.
Holy moly.
Oh!
Sick.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
We got a mop.
People are...
Just trying to use the force.
Having the puddle right in front of the seat is kind of evil.
Damn, Ruby, you got tan!
We gotta clean up more trash, everybody.
I just saved her life, I really did.
Wait, do I have to clean out?
Why is it like an old-fashioned porta potty?
Excuse me, everybody, excuse me.
Management coming through.
Is this supposed to be my rating?
Does a park in Oregon where you have to pay for every single ride you go on?
What?
No way.
It's called an outhouse.
We're in 2025.
Alright.
Eevee!
Ibuy!
For four hours.
I can't wait till I can hire staff to do all this menial...
tasks adult okay mr worldwide i got you yeah is the admission cheap like if it's okay five dollars is not a lot to come in but also there's nothing here so like i feel like i should be charging like it should be free oh sorry oh please move no no please everybody get out of the way It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
I got your gamer subs cup.
I've been enjoying using the different flavors to change your color.
Thank you.
More garbage.
Imagine you slide down the slide right into the poo.
Oh my gosh.
I saw you throw that in there.
Disgusting.
Poop on the slide.
Oh.
Did I do that?
Oh my god, they're all dead.
No, there's no poop on the slide.
Wait, I'm gonna use it.
Cowabunga!
I'm surprised anybody can swim in this, I'm not gonna lie.
So we can have a max of...
Oh, 5 plus 2.
Because it says it on the top left.
You see that?
What time do we close?
It's almost 6 p.m.
Hey you, you ever wanted to go to a park?
Best day ever.
They're loving this.
Yeah, yeah, come in, come in.
Or not.
Oh!
Reviews.
Twelve injured...
Well, no.
Twelve...
Twelve visitors had injured thought.
Ten visitors had slipped thought.
Nine visitors had tired thought.
Nine visitors had low trash thought.
Good reviews.
19 visitors had used clean attraction thought.
Yes, when I get injured, I often think, ah, my, ah, I got injured.
That's my thought.
I thought about getting injured.
This is the most insane water park ever.
One rusty slide.
The outhouse bathroom's a poopy pool and the owner slams you with a sledgehammer.
That wasn't for a criminal.
I took justice into my own hands.
Savage Fisherman Joe.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
19 visitors had energized thought.
17 visitors had fun thought.
We lost $53.
Satisfaction, 65%.
You need to unlock tipping.
Wait, I have to...
I'm begging for more money?
One visitor had dropped massive crap at the pool thought.
Yeah, who was that?
Who the heck did that?
Yeah, I'm blocking the bad reviews.
They're right behind my head here.
Maybe I'll move over like here.
I don't think there's too much.
There's like my task list on the right side, but I think it's okay.
Sorry, hold on.
Okay.
I'm going to sue your park.
I slipped and tore my ACL.
Uh, you signed the waiver.
You signed the waiver.
Uh, now what?
Use the printer to print out flyers and give them to pedestrians.
Okay.
Our park?
It's pretty clean.
Where's the water coming from?
Oh, I...
Oh, oh, I see it.
Dirty, dirty.
This is just...
I guess we have to get rid of these because...
No one's using them.
They kind of look good for atmosphere, but maybe it's also kind of trashy.
Hi-jai!
You knew what you signed up for.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, so we close at 6 p.m.
Ah, what a hard day's work.
Who cleans the porta-potties?
Oh, it's actually extremely clean.
Just kidding.
All right, I'm feeling good here.
Let's go hand out some flyers.
Just looking around at everything.
My glory.
So clean since nobody's using it.
They're all using...
The pool.
Oh, you need to open the park to poach.
I'm poaching people now?
Phoebe!
Phoebe, Phoebe, Phoebe, Phoebe.
Phoebe, watch what I can do.
Help!
Ready, ready, ready.
That one's for you.
Hi, Phoebe.
Hello.
Hello, beehive.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that one, actually.
Thank you, Darko.
Thank you, take up a yin-yang.
My, what a large number of broken bones you have.
Wait, so why is it telling me to print out flyers and give to people if I can't even do that?
Game wide to me?
What, so we just...
We sleep?
We don't turn off the water?
Oh!
Can I go in here?
The void of...
When you go in, you become...
You wear a bathing suit?
This is my tent?
I have no home!
Minto!
I thought people were camping outside, excited for my park!
Okay, hold on.
Is there anything else I can build?
No, I think we're, like, pretty tutorial limited right now.
That's okay, though.
I'll pick up the trash.
I'll move it over here.
so I want to keep using it.
Pick up my tools.
Alright, team.
We are ready.
We are G2G.
Good to go.
Hello?
Hey!
Oh!
Don't think I didn't see you!
Kill!
Kill him!
First thing in the morning.
I'm a small business.
owner yeah you better run you better run denver you'll never be safe again in this town i think i saw a banana hey ruby didn't i let you in yesterday what are all these people coming in thinking that i i'm just running a
okay hello slide pass adult for four hours i got you
This isn't what I...
Wait, what did you...
Wait, I
think I messed up.
Let's go pass out some flyers.
I don't think anybody's in there.
They would be in the pool.
Yeah.
Boring!
Research.
Uh...
Your progress fuels discovery.
Gain XP from every action you take and once you've gathered enough, you'll be able to earn research points.
Head over to the research table in the tool shed and unlock the hot dog stand!
Wait.
This rocks!
Yeah, baby.
What about you?
Oh, I already want a ticket, yeah?
Alright, yeah, baby!
Everybody come to the park!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need a lot of money.
Denver!
He's paying properly now.
Oh, they all are.
Senior slide pass.
They're paying properly now.
Ruth, I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to actually kill you.
Once I deal with these people, I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill you, Ruth.
I'm going to kill you.
There's two of them.
It looks like one of your guests has gotten cold feet on the diving board.
and give him a little encouragement.
Oh, okay.
Death to you and who's the other one?
Oh, what the hell just happened?
You?
Death, death, death, death, death.
Okay, hello, adult pass for eight hours.
Yeah, you get out of here, Ruth.
Four hours, slide, adult.
Who's laughing?
Someone is drowning!
Grab a ring from the...
Oh my gosh!
I'm a lifeguard too!
Oh my god!
Uh...
How do I help you?
You're welcome!
Hello.
Four hours.
Mr. Senior.
How do you drown in here?
Like, watching people go down the slide is so funny.
Okay.
Very good.
Our place is...
Our place is hustling and bustling.
Get the fuck out of here, Cade.
Get the hell out of here.
I don't want you in my park.
Ever again.
Oh.
Leonard is drowning!
You just got in here!
Wait.
Where's my...
Oh, there it is.
Saved by the best.
Camille.
Beat him.
I will.
Lily.
Four adult slide pass.
That's why you're the best, boss.
Hee-hee.
Okay, everybody good?
No trash?
No poo?
No water?
Oh, the game is glistening out a little bit.
Whoa.
Oh.
There is trash.
Don't worry, I'll handle it.
Don't be upset about the trash.
Let me in between your legs, please, sir.
Thank you.
My trash bag is full.
This park is so cool and free.
Wait, I can't feel my legs.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Okay, watch him go.
he paid two dollars for that experience go go go we just go limp as soon as they you know i think i should carry around the trash bag oh excuse me let's put away this
i think like these are three essentials no cartman strategy we got pools right Rise, lazy wizard?
Riz- Riz- Riz- Riz-
I didn't mean to say that!
Lazy, lazy wizard.
Aw, man!
Oh yeah, that's right, we're supposed to go to the this.
We gotta get this.
the hot dog stand.
Let's forget everything that I just said.
It's like a pass for the lazy wizard.
It's my birthday on the 28th!
I was too busy to send a super jammy, so I'm happy birthday from my mug-shelot-loving Yoshi.
Spicy cheese nips!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Ah.
Hold on, let me blow my nose.
Let me blow my... Oh, no!
My thing Tor weird.
Paging Dr. Freud.
What are you talking about?
Freud.
Why is he here?
I have a chocolate rocket horse.
Yeah.
Are you still sick?
Yeah, just a little bit.
Well, honestly, I'm getting better pretty...
Oh.
Oh, the game is still going.
It doesn't pause here.
Okay.
Hello, Jameson.
Eight hours?
What are you gonna do for eight whole hours, huh?
Thank you.
Oh my god, there's people dying!
Oh my god!
Wait!
What just happened?
Ah!
What
are you doing?
I thought the game would pause!
When we...
When we were at the table!
Oh wait!
Was she gonna have like a...
Like a... I died in the pool thought?
Oh, Andres, how could you not manage to avoid drowning?
How could you...
Oh!
Guess waited too long for a ticket.
No, no!
I didn't know you were there!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Oh gosh, this is getting a little chaotic, no?
Hey, are you supposed to be in here?
Oh, he's the medic.
Oh.
How are you carrying?
Okay.
What are you gonna do to him?
Not...
Oh.
Oh my god.
What are you...
Ah!
I dreaded this!
Oh no!
Sir, I think we need a second ambulance.
Good golly.
Oh, I could have revived him, I think, with the injector.
Maybe?
Oh, no, there's garbage.
Don't worry, I got it, team.
There's no poop yet, which is great.
We've only lost one life.
We've only lost a life.
if it's fine.
Game has no chill.
I need to, um...
I almost hit the medic because I thought he was trying to steal.
Or, you know, they're trying to get in for free.
Okay, we're gonna get hot dogs down.
I did it.
Press bleed.
Okay.
Oh no!
No no no!
No!
Don't think garbage thoughts!
Okay.
Bleed.
We're gonna...
Not decoration, utility.
Here we go.
We'll put it like...
right here.
Customer thought.
Hey that manager, lifeguard, ticket sales, maintenance girl is pretty cute.
Really?
Mint Phantom presents Action Park.
This is so crazy.
We've only lost one life.
Mint Phantom owner.
Oh, the game is still going.
Oh my gosh, it's so dirty.
Everything is so nasty over here.
They really...
Oh, the day is over.
I need to remember that the game does not end.
The game does not pause.
It's just like real life.
Real life, real afterlife does not pause.
It's pretty clean.
Oh I gotta build this, not sledgehammer.
Regular hammer.
okay hot dog shortage uh-oh your stands out of hot dogs come back to a water park for just the water no oh oh no no sorry no one comes to a water park for just the water sorry i'm so i think i'm sick i got my wisdom teeth pulled and watching me don't beat pedestrians over the head with a sledgehammer is exactly what I needed.
Nicholas, feel better.
Um, sprint across the street to the store and grab a box of fresh hot dogs.
Time is meat.
Don't keep them waiting.
Oh, well, the park is closed, so I think we're okay, but we can have the hot dogs just kind of like chilling overnight, right?
Welcome to Kmart.
Oh, welcome to Kmart.
It's a back massage.
Look at them.
Flipy Flops.
Swim Park.
Simulator.
What's wrong with me?
I can't speak.
I'm sorry, everybody.
Oh, these are not unlocked yet.
Okay.
No space in inventory.
Oh, geez.
One hot dog, please.
One moment, please.
them right now.
Zanzibar land, five stars.
You see it there first, folks.
Oh, nice.
We don't even have to cook them.
Hot dogs.
No staff.
I survived Minke's class action park.
Does it say now staff?
Well, it still says no staff.
No, I'm the staff.
Sell hot dog.
Oh, no, we'll sell tomorrow.
Okay.
First thing in the morning, baby.
Liz, more than six in action park will be dethroned as the deadliest water park.
Let's shoot for 40.
I can't believe we killed a bat.
Well, okay, but like...
Was it our fault?
Because I can stand in this pool.
You know?
I don't think it was our fault.
You and me?
We?
Us?
A collective?
All of us here.
We were all in on it.
How do you drown in a pool even Minx can stand in?
That's what I'm saying.
Not all guests are equal.
Every now and then a special guest might show up.
Some loud, some funny, I'm just playing stinky.
Oh, maybe that's why that guy was playing the game, Kesa.
Keep an eye on them.
Make sure they don't spoil the fun for your regular guests.
What do I do if they are here?
This seems kind of rude.
Wait, what do I do to him?
Hello.
Oh.
I murder him.
I push him down the stairs.
Apparently.
Well, he didn't pay anyway, so
Hello!
Six hours?
Oh my god!
This seems mean!
Four hours, adult.
Wait, is that a person that paid or no?
Six hours, teen.
Slide pass.
Wait, there's so many people coming in that are just...
Do you have a pass?
I don't think they did.
Senior 4-Hour Slide Pass.
I think there was somebody else, too.
Guys, keep a lookout for the wristbands.
Wait, you don't have one.
Make it stop.
Oh, oh.
Add mustard.
Dojo?
Add both.
Dojo.
Oh, I think I took too long.
This is getting a little bit.
little nuts, you guys.
This is getting a little intense.
Now we have to worry about hot dogs.
We have to worry about people.
We have to worry about everything.
Ah!
Out of order.
It's broken?
I can fix it.
Repair.
Don't walk on it while I'm repairing it.
Aha!
Very good.
Oh, wait, these need to get repaired too?
You have to pay to use the bathroom?
Who's crying?
There's somebody.
Okay.
Alright.
So far, I think we can pass out some flyers, maybe.
It's a little chill right now.
It's pretty chill.
It's not even noon.
Hello, hello!
Hello!
Oh, you already want a ticket.
Okay, just kidding.
Where is everybody?
Oh, hello, hello!
You already want a ticket.
Wait, are you coming in now?
A customer!
Hello!
Adult?
Uh-oh.
One moment, please.
One moment.
Oh, Lena!
Lena, I got you!
okay
extra if you pay you would pay extra for the mallet really I'll do it four hour adult okay very good very nice let's pick up some trash I don't know where I oh there's my garbage bag I don't know if this is full or not I can't tell okay I can't You can't tell how to tell,
you know.
Excuse me, no littering in my pool.
Excuse me, excuse me, excuse me.
Ah, shoot.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
The way she jumped back after almost drowning.
Oh.
Hello.
Add both.
Miss the bin?
Ah!
What did I do with my...
Oh, they're just tiny trash.
What a jerk.
Did you wash your hands?
I'm...
I work at a swim...
Oh, gosh.
I work at a swim park.
Wash my hands.
All I gotta do is go into the water, baby.
Easy peasy.
Plane.
I'm in desperate need.
Go.
Don't complain to me unless...
I think you need staff, Minto.
I agree.
I would love some staff to help me.
Axton, why'd you do that?
Get out of my way.
Why are you yelling about trash?
Yell at the other people.
Don't yell at me.
I'm doing my best.
Well, don't get mad at the park.
Get mad at the people who are littering.
the park.
I would have last three seconds with this job with my stress tolerance.
Why are we upset?
Oh, hello, plane.
Got you.
What's...
Oh, my...
Wait, we're at zero star.
One adult pass with changing room, bathroom, combo, and the hot dog meal ticket combo.
Also, how much is the Summer Minto plush?
That one?
You have to pay per minute that you own it.
These people are animals.
I agree.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, don't do that.
Watch out, Axton!
Watch out!
Axton!
Oh my gosh.
Finish tutorial.
lifeguard-ish is the thing I got.
Wait, I can't find my trash.
I throw my stuff all over the place.
I think I threw it up here, yeah.
Okay.
And we got a ping pong.
No, it ex- No!
Oh, no!
Hello!
Um, oh my gosh.
No kidding.
What the hell?
Just for
hours!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
So mean!
I'm having the worst day of my afterlife.
Wait, I thought this was broken.
Okay.
Trash dupes.
Oh.
Oh, I thought I couldn't tell if this was a shadow or dirt, but it is a shadow.
No, it's dirt.
Sorry.
Wait, what is this?
Levi is panicking.
What is this?
Oh, I'm repairing it.
Whatever it is.
The filter.
Clean filter?
Oh, now it's nice and clean.
What?
There's nothing in there.
What the hell is that?
Wait, why is there like...
There's amoeba growing in my...
Okay, oh gosh, guys, we're harvesting it.
COVID-2025.
This is, we're incubating COVID-2025.
It's here.
Can I get you off of this, or...
Who's in my dumpster?
Oh.
Gosh.
Okay, we're at 6.
Oh.
Are you okay, Lina?
What just happened?
Lina is waiting for a hot dog.
I got you.
What do you want?
Add both.
Yes, ma'am.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Catch it!
Catch it, Arlo!
Everything is fine, everybody.
Oh, my trash bag is full.
Everything is fine.
water parks but mint water part water water water I your your message is gonna give me a stroke okay four hours
oh well somebody what I thought this game was gonna be kind of chill this is insanity
Nah, it's chill, we're chill.
It's chill, we're chill, we're cool, we're chill.
Everything's cool, we're chill.
Wait, this thing.
Now I can finally repair.
Wait, did it... Is it dirty?
Or is it... Wait.
Oh, it's not clean!
Oh!
No, no, no, no, stop!
Yeah, you deserve that.
They're all dirty.
It's okay, I'm scrubbing them with the same thing that I scrubbed the ground and scrubbed the...
I scrub everything the same.
Equal opportunity.
Add ketchup.
We're gonna have to go get more dogs soon.
Get your first star.
I have to sell tickets.
Three out of 15.
Oh, I have to build a trash bin and build a shower.
A trash bin would be...
That would be huge.
Where is it though?
Here?
Oh, maybe I have to unlock it.
Okay, hold on.
No.
Park?
Oh, the trash bin, trash bin.
Rusty shower.
Okay, alright, alright, nice, nice, nice.
Oh!
Max!
Max, I got you!
He's still paying.
Yeah.
Yeah, Max, I get it.
It do be like that.
Let's see.
Bad reviews.
Nine visitors had low trash thought.
Six visitors had injured thought.
Five visitors had decoration level thought.
Four visitors had drowning thought.
Raiden!
Good reviews.
23 visitors had energized thought 12 visitors had used clean attraction thought you were feet i received a fine for the ambulance no
11 visitors had fun thought seven visitors had oh we're closed are
they gonna be okay doc give it to me straight are they gonna be okay i didn't i really was it i didn't mean it at all i went as fast as i could i promise max you you hang in there
you hang in there max
holy moly okay let's build the showers and the trash can.
We'll build one there.
And it says build two showers.
Okay, showers, here we go.
We'll put the showers like over here.
I kind of want to do like a theme, but I feel like I will do a theme once we unlock more stuff.
Why is it always crooked?
We'll like make a better theme and stuff once,
paging Dr. Howard, Dr. Fine, Dr. Howard, Dr. Turn off my drowning inhibitors.
Okay.
Alright, wait.
You know what?
I'm even going to do a second trash can.
Buy the toilet.
Wait, how much money do I have?
Oh, it's only $20 for a trash can.
Okay, we're fine.
I have 755 bucks.
Let's go.
Please let me have staff soon.
please please what does research do well it lets you unlock things to get but it's like they're not unlocked at all so I don't really understand oh I think once I get to one star of my park then I can unlock more things ah so we really need to unlock or rather once we sell 15 tickets We will be at one star park.
I think.
Staff in level one?
Yippee!
Awesome.
I think you need more pools.
Should we build a second pool?
Where can we put it?
Maybe in the corner.
Right here.
Need more slides?
Oh, we need more pools.
For slides.
We'll just put it in the corner.
Nobody puts pool baby in the corner.
This kind of cuts into the...
Wait.
Let's...
Wait, just kidding.
I'm gonna move this trash can to like here.
It doesn't really matter.
It's a trash can.
Just kidding.
Uh, okay.
And then you.
Okay.
This one will be a little exciting.
It'll be at a diagonal.
If I can.
If it'll let me.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, everybody wait right by the porta potty.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Second pool?
Oh, we are in business, baby.
Okay.
We are so in business.
Oh, this thing needs to get clean too.
Everything's dirty.
Everything's so nasty.
Okay.
And you need to be repaired at all?
Oh, yeah, you do.
It was good.
Oh, this thing was about to break any second.
We could have killed more people.
I don't... I actually kind of don't want more people coming to my park.
I'm scared.
Now, you guys, there's going to be so much water.
work oh oh i'm drowning i'm just trying to leave okay okay i'm gonna move also let's move you over by the dumpster and the hot dog stand to go a little further down too now that guy should have no troubles going from the hot dog stand to the bathroom
Welcome to action, Minto Park.
Please don't sue us.
Okay.
Keep everything here.
Oh, my...
Wait.
Oh, my little tiny trash bag.
Right, everything is all together?
Wait, where did my sledgehammer go?
Why... How did you get over here?
That's strange.
Alright, good.
Okay, sleep time.
Are you...
Hot dogs!
Thank you, guys.
Yeah, we need more hot dogs.
Yes.
More hot dogs.
We are all clean.
We're all stocked.
Oops.
We're fine.
Yes.
Um, is this clean?
No, I think about it.
Maybe I do need to clean this.
Oh!
I think I also need to, like, fix it.
They're not stored appropriately.
Oh, no.
No, they're perfectly stored.
Guys?
Would you come to my water park?
For eight hours.
For eight whole hours?
Need churros.
That's a great idea.
Why are the hot dogs already buttoned and cooked?
Don't ask.
Don't...
Say it.
Don't spray it.
24 hour pass!
Aww.
Alright, we're gonna hit our goal today.
We're gonna get one stars.
Are there Japanese amusement park treats you wish were a thing in America?
Oh, well, I once went to Tokyo Disney Sea during the summer and they just sold whole mango on a stick and it was great.
I would, I would like that.
Good morning!
Six hour teen bash.
Yeah, it was just a mango.
It wasn't like a mango bar or anything.
Like, it was...
was an actual mango.
Oh, I got a new research point.
Adult with the slide pass.
Yeah, I wish we, I wish mango were real.
I'm both.
Thank you.
Someone in there?
Oh, let's get my loady out.
Before I...
You know, there we go.
Everything's good.
Ah, they're taking showers!
Oh my gosh, they're using the facilities!
$5, please?
$5.
Oh, $1.
Why is the music so loud all of a sudden?
I think we should pass out more flyers.
because nobody's here.
It's kind of sad.
Thank you.
Anybody drowning?
Everyone's alive?
Trash?
Where?
Is there a lazy river yet?
Almost soon, probably.
Probably tomorrow I can, you know, carve that out.
Hello?
Senior.
Six hours.
Thank you.
Add both.
Oh, I see the trash.
Please
ignore our mess.
Please, thank you.
Ding, mung.
Six hour adult.
I think I'm about to murder somebody.
You're fine.
Die.
Get the hell out of my park.
Get the hell out of my park and think again about cheating me.
Huh?
This is my livelihood.
Hello.
Six hours in there.
Is everybody alive?
Okay.
I gotta set an exam.
everybody.
Where's my money, Lepowski?
No!
Oops.
Oh, I slipped on the banana.
How embarrassing.
Okay, nobody saw that.
Puddles are so dangerous here.
They're like made of the slipperyest goo ever in the world.
No, no poops in the pool.
Okay, we're Great.
Oh, I got an achievement.
I mopped 100 puddles.
I'm gonna build a second toilet just in case.
I think people would appreciate that.
You know?
Pools of ectoplasm.
Yes!
Yes, actually.
Add mustard.
It was pushing me.
Oh, are you okay?
Someone missed the toilet, I guess.
We just need three more tickets.
Three more, and we're good.
For one star, we can unlock so many things.
Oh, um, um, um, uh, uh, no, sir.
Ma'am?
No person.
Okay, we need more flyers.
Yeah, you cry about it.
You cry about it.
Already wants a ticket.
Then he should have paid for it!
Oh, please.
Don't leave.
Yeah, yeah, have a blast.
Have a blast.
Do you want to take it already?
Yeah, I already want to take it.
Wait, these might be our last people.
This might be it.
Hold on.
Your hot dog will wait.
4 hour senior pass Too many MFs Threatening mids live, I know!
People really do be trifling with me It's okay though I got the sledgehammer
Teen?
Are you sure?
Yippee!
We do it!
Add mustard Thank you Oh, oh, lots of puddles, everybody.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Oh, come on, you guys!
Who's dying?
Who's screaming?
Wait, caught a cheater.
Oh, okay.
Everyone decides to walk into the puddles all at the same time.
Add both.
Senior citizen discount?
Eight hours.
Okay, Miriam.
Jeez.
All right, we're gonna go after this.
People dying be damned.
I think we gotta do some...
Actually, no, we'll do all the research at night.
That might be too risky.
People just be drowning every two seconds.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Excuse me, please.
What's wrong with my pool?
Wait, why is my pool empty?
Oh, God.
Don't use them!
Don't use it if it's F!
It's F!
Stop!
Stop using!
Stop the slides!
Why is it empty?
Oh no, is he dead?
Oh, I think I can save him.
I can save him!
That was close!
You're telling me!
Oh my gosh, Lima.
Oh my god.
Stop using the slides!
It's out of order!
I received a fa- Stop!
This is a disaster.
Stella, you cannot find me.
You did this to yourself.
How do I repair what it want?
Oh, I think I just repair it like this.
I thought it had something to do with the...
Oh, my God.
This is an actual disaster.
Okay, everybody?
We're fine.
Stella, I'm not touching you.
You literally find me before.
You will be fine.
Oh, my gosh.
This is turning into chaos hell world.
Yes, plane?
Okay, I got you.
Guess waited too long.
I just got to him!
Eight hours.
Adult.
Slide pass.
There you go, Carla.
Four hours.
Yeah, we need staff pronto.
Yorn.
Slide pass.
Smelly guess!
A smelly guess has entered my park.
Their stink is reducing hygiene.
Unlock the water gun.
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh.
No!
How do I use it?
Wait.
Do I just...
Where do I get it?
In here?
Oh, here it is.
Gosh, dang it.
Miriam is drowning!
Oh.
Oops.
It'll reach.
Ah, okay.
Alright, we're fine.
There's trash everywhere.
There's everything, everything all at once.
Requires a trash bag.
Wait, oh, I'm stupid.
I'm right clicking.
Everybody's tripping.
Everything is bad.
The world is on fire.
I don't want to be an entrepreneur anymore.
I regret this life.
Oh, I'm slipping.
I hate the service.
Take the mob!
Everybody's slipping.
I'm slipping.
They're slipping.
We're all slipping.
Please move!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna be- I'm gonna go broke because I'm gonna have no money from all the lawsuits.
Why did I build this pool?
Why did I built this park on rock.
I should have done it.
I should have done it on on like a little like a squishy pad or something.
Boy, what is this?
Oh, we got pizza.
Okay, fine.
Wait, what are you doing?
Get in there.
Uh oh.
What's happening?
Oh, you need medical assistance or...
Uh oh.
Are you drowning?
Oh, heal again.
Day's over!
Uh.
He just stood there and took it.
Why are my pools breaking so fast all of a sudden?
Are you gonna leave?
Parks closed, buddy.
Customers playing rough.
I'm fighting for my afterlife over here for real.
Let him stay.
I will.
Alright.
Maybe the tutorial was like...
Crazy easy.
If we get...
Okay, Road the second star is clearing 20 tracks.
okay yeah we're gonna get staff i don't feel like you can't research stuff while the park is open because it's it's absolute chaos it's like insanity for real is this oh
i didn't mean to do that but that was fun okay i need my trash bag
No trash there.
Gather trash.
Oh.
Oh, he's leaving.
See ya.
See you tomorrow.
Bye.
Don't slip on the way out.
Take it easy.
Bye.
He's completely tripping in his suit.
Maybe we need to actually provide towels for these savages.
These people are crazy.
Everybody here is crazy.
They don't know how to swim and they go to parks.
They...
Back to the office.
What was I?
What did I see?
That was just like, it's a swimsuit and it's all...
of a suit.
Okay, let's repair everything.
Tip-top shape.
It's because they're not stretching before going in.
Must be.
Everybody is insane here.
Even the bathrooms are treated so poorly.
Actually, that's just everybody, though.
That's in real life, too.
Nobody Nobody treats things with care.
Now, if you ever feel like I'm making a mess of a bathroom, remember this stream.
Remember all the pain and suffering I've gone through.
And be like, you know what?
There's somebody just like Minto who is suffering.
Trying to clean everything.
I should be kinder.
I'm trying to be kinder.
Don't tempt me.
You're like, oh, wait.
Minto is, uh, clean in this place?
Okay, I think I've cleaned and repaired everything.
Does this need to be cleaner repaired?
We gotta get more hot dogs, though.
And then we shall...
Um...
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
Then we will, um...
Buy stuff.
Oh, I guess they give you the boxing glove so that you can punch intruders.
That's fun.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so stuffly.
I work in janitorial maintenance and it feels like nobody cares about hygiene Oh the worst Okay let's let's upgrade Unlocks a stand with inflatable life rings to assist in quick water rescues Okay, so I have eight points Increase walk Okay, maintenance Where are the staff?
Where are the staff?
Cache your staff.
Oh, if I get paintbrush, okay.
Things stay cleaner for longer.
That would be four.
And this would be four.
I think that would be good.
Bigger pockets.
Oh, wait.
That's huge, too.
But I think, first of all, Cache your staff.
That's huge.
Oh, we get to paint now.
Okay.
Press tab, open the higher men now.
You have to pay them daily, but they keep the park running smoothly most of the time.
Sometimes staff take breaks, and when they do, their work simply stops.
Higher.
Why are their efficiencies so low?
Wait, this person's pretty good.
30% efficiency.
Oh, wait, but this person has crazy endurance.
A lot more stats than I expected.
Me too!
Don't hire them until tomorrow.
Okay.
Good plan.
Yeah.
Alright, what else can we do?
Let's see.
Simple and functional toilets.
Oh, this would be different toilets than what we have.
Pick a trash bag.
Basic pool.
Generous tip.
Pockets lead to handyman.
You're right.
Wait, but this is repair.
Okay, actually repair worker is huge.
Okay, you're right.
We could do both.
No, we can't.
Ah, I have to get the shower.
That's fine.
I think staff is biggest at the moment.
Here's janitorial staff.
Oh, I should have gone with this, huh?
Oh, shoot.
That's okay.
We'll just get more research points.
Sorry, we're all stuffed on, Minto.
When I was a kid, I was feeling stuffy.
I would say my nose is all hogged up.
I don't remember why.
That's so cute.
reminds me um when i was a kid we would do road trips with my family and uh we would always go to the same place during the summer but it was like really really far it was a super long drive and there was one restaurant we would always stop at in the middle of the drive but i didn't know the difference between states and restaurants So I would always call the restaurant the state.
And I would be like, I want to go to that state.
And they'd be like, you mean the restaurant, Minto?
And I was like, yeah, I want to go to the state.
So like, if it was like, for example, Texas, I'd be like, I want to go to Texas.
But I meant a restaurant.
Let's all eat at Colorado.
So I would do that.
And even now when I see that restaurant, I'm like, yeah.
There's that restaurant.
There's that state.
Takes a special state of mind.
Okay, so we have some...
What did I get?
Oh, we're going to get the handyman.
next we're gonna get the handyman we got 14 out of 20 trash cleared there's nothing in here right no i think we've repaired everything and cleaned everything so i think we're good to oh oh oh okay now i think we're good to go i need to stop throwing away bags because they Okay.
Oh, I forgot I got bigger pockets!
We can hold, like, everything now.
Okay.
All right, let's go see.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
All right.
Good morning, Minto!
Let's hire some people.
Let's hire somebody.
Oh, wait.
No, it was a...
Here.
Oh, tab.
All right.
Wait, these prices are way more Than before Or am I crazy?
Yeah, dude, they're way more expensive than before What happened?
Hi?
So expensive Um Better stats Oh geez Okay, um I feel like this is a good middle ground Well actually maybe this Okay This person has a lot of endurance.
Efficiency.
You know what?
How much money do I have?
We could always fire him.
$2.75 per day.
This person might be better, actually.
They have more endurance.
I think actually we'll go with Braylon.
Massachusetts, it's my favorite fried fish joint.
Yugi, my boy.
Yugi boy.
Maximilian Pegasus.
Do we go with Maximilian Pegasus or do we go with Braylon?
I'm just gonna hire Braylon.
All right.
Come on in, Braylon.
Oh!
Hired my first staff.
All right, let's get the park open.
Baby?
I will go take out flyers.
Hello, we're open for business!
Oh, here they come, here they come!
Whoa.
Oh, what about you?
You don't know about my business.
Don't yawn at me.
Yeah!
Yep!
Are you doing it?
Do I need to leave?
Okay.
Hi, Earl.
Thank you so much for the bid to give to thank you.
I hear California has some good rolls.
California rolls.
In fact, I'm going to get the water gun on the ready.
Or we could get the...
Wait.
Uh-oh.
This.
The life ring on the ready.
You're paying, right?
You're all paying the...
Come in!
Okay.
Alright.
So far so good.
So far not so bad.
What is this?
Oh.
Medkit injector.
I got painting.
Oh yeah, I did get that.
We can start coloring stuff.
Wow.
We can start coloring things.
Let's see.
This one.
Oh.
Wait, we're a hot dog!
Add both.
Thank you.
Where did I drop that?
There it is.
Oh, research floor tool.
Oh wait, how can I change the color?
Uh oh.
Um.
Wait.
I'm painting everything brown.
Wait, no!
I don't want it all Right click?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, someone's waiting for a hot dog.
Hello.
Plan.
Braylin screwed up an order.
Braylin!
Bjorn is drowning!
Saved by the best, baby.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, he's so excited.
He's so excited about- he's going down backwards!
This is how you- Bjorn, this is how you're gonna drown!
Gonna pee to your ool- No!
Crunko!
Don't do it!
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you.
Celebrate life.
My man was so excited that he lived.
Wait, so what if I do this?
Raelin again?
Wait, this costs money.
But I guess people will appreciate the fun color, right?
Yeah, it's kind of nice.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh, oh, me too.
I'm down.
Yeah, it's a pretty standard water park color.
It looks nice, I think.
I think it looks good.
People are going to be very excited by the...
Bright and colorful, fun colors.
Everything is blue.
Blue, blue, blue.
I love blue.
My name is Mint, but I love blue.
Oh, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Everything is blue.
Da-ba-dee-da-ba-da.
Blue.
Wait, this looks fancy, actually.
Blue phantom.
Yeah.
You okay?
Oh my gosh!
Don't sleep there Arlo, you're gonna get a tan.
He regrets everything.
Gosh, these pools get so dirty so fast.
Yes, we did too long.
Oh, I didn't realize there was someone waiting for a hot dog.
Oh, I'm here!
Hello!
Add both.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, 9 out of 10 throw.
Let's go.
Someone's dead over here?
Oh, sorry, Phoenix.
I didn't mean to run into you.
You got someone waiting for a hot dog?
Hello.
Ad mustard.
Dozo, my lady.
Someone too afraid to...
Get in there.
Oh, there's trash.
Not on my watch.
Dirt's in damage.
Traction.
Slowly lose dirt.
Oh, yeah, we know this.
Oh, yeah, I know this.
I know this all too well.
Why did you fall asleep?
I just fed you!
Ariel!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, it's a
little freaky, you guys.
Skinwalker.
Don't do that!
It's out of order!
Can't you read!
Is Braylon still there?
Or...
Oh yeah, he is.
Is he still doing his job?
I think he's about almost done, so we're gonna have to take over for him.
No, no!
Don't get off!
I'm trying to clean the slide!
Oh wait, I painted it poopy brown.
I thought it was just dirty.
No, it's me.
I did that.
What's in those hot dogs?
Why do you think I say hot dog?
I cannonballed inside your empty pool and broke my butt.
Um.
This place needs to be shut down.
No, it's not.
It's my livelihood, please.
Ow!
Hello.
What would you like?
Mustard.
Thank you.
What would you like?
Anything?
Anything trash in here?
No?
You can sue yourself.
No, I'm doing an amazing job!
Please!
Oh, sorry.
Just, like, stay out of my way, okay?
These filters?
Okay.
All clean.
Oh wait, COVID-25, COVID-25!
COVID-25 alert!
This is Mint Phantom's water park for the clinically insane.
I'm sure he's fraud enthusiast.
No!
What do you mean?
I think this one's dirty.
Cleaning it while they're on it.
Ah!
Oh, I got a new research point.
Let's go.
Wait, we can maybe go by the staff now.
Everything is deteriorating at an exponential rate.
I'm... I think Ariel is really far gone.
Team, let's all stop slipping on this, please.
If I drown myself, will you give me CPR?
wide.
I need trash.
Trash.
You nasty creatures.
All of you.
Oh.
Hello.
Plane.
I got you.
I got you, queen.
Out of order!
Uh-oh.
Okay, hold on.
What do you want, plane?
Okay.
Hot dogs will have to wait.
What's out of order?
Oh, this thing.
Okay.
That's just like totally normal for a...
for a theme park though, no?
This thing is about to fall the hell apart.
I'm keeping up with market standards.
It's market standards, everybody.
Get in there.
Enjoy the pool.
Stinky trash.
I got it.
We're good.
Let's repair these two.
Kobe.
Cleaning.
New research point.
Oops.
I think I just threw the trash in here.
Oh no, where did I put it?
Oh, there it is.
Oof.
Everything's fine.
Oh no!
One moment, please.
Oh.
Oh, the day is over.
Oh, thank God.
Hi, dog.
That's what I needed.
Blue!
Thank you so much for those.
Spooky.
So happy.
My name is Blue.
She loves me.
Okay, bad reviews.
Eight visitors.
Or 18 visitors had tired thought.
Okay, we need to make more chairs.
13 visitors had slip thought.
Slipknot?
Do you have a license for that, Amma?
Yes, sir.
I do.
Sage, thank you so much for the part.
I'm going to do that too.
10 visitors had low trash thought.
8 visitors had decoration level thought.
You don't like blue?
They don't like the...
Good reviews.
29 visitors had energized thought.
26 visitors had used clean attraction thought.
14 visitors had fun thought.
And 8 visitors had full thought.
Wow, they're having full thought.
Ariel!
Ariel, are you okay?
It's time to go home!
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Whoa.
Guys, I think she's really into me.
Whoa, whoa.
Ariel?
Oh, under the sea.
Under the sea.
Oh, darling, it's better.
Down where?
Down where it's better.
Take it from me!
Man.
You...
Ma'am, you are...
You have become a statue.
I think your tan is, like, insane.
Damn, girl.
That body of yours.
No, I'm actually concerned.
Okay.
Tandyman staff.
And then we'll do bigger trash bags so we can lead to janitor staff.
I think would be good.
Oh, wait.
Maintenance decoration, little one.
Adds a bit of...
I can afford this.
Did I hear someone walking?
It wasn't aerial.
Restock required.
Spraylan.
What are you doing?
How do you beat the game?
I don't know.
I guess you become the greatest
water park in the world.
Minto needs a spray tan.
Yeah, going back to that story about about how I got made fun of for how pale I used to be or I still am, but how I used to get made fun of for it.
There was one girl that I knew and her family owned a place that did like tanning.
Like, uh...
What's the word?
No, stop it doing that!
Uh, fake the spray tans!
And so I tried it.
Okay, I didn't even go down.
But anyway, I tried it, um...
And then everyone still made fun of me.
They were like, now you're orange!
I could never win.
I,
you know, now I'm kind of more like, I look like a little more human-like, but I was, I was like pretty wisp-like before, you know, I didn't have so much energy to take on, like, a shape, and so I was kind of like blue-green, you know, I was pretty mint.
It's like not.
It's just like, it just does not mix well.
Would you be freak phantom if you weren't pale?
What does that have to do with it?
Oh, I'm, oh.
Doing it.
Whatever that guy's name was.
Braxton style, whatever his name was.
Okay.
Preparing everything, the 100%.
Cleaning everything, 100%.
I haven't touched the bathrooms.
They're probably about to crumble.
This one, one thing this game is teaching me is that people are slobs.
I feel like this game comes very, um, like out of a, a place of, like, extreme anger.
Like, it feels very personal.
Or interesting.
mint tea sounds kind of yummy really is this okay no why don't they use this one oh maybe
it was broken hmm let's change our slide back to blue there it is I can't live like this I can't live with with the with the slide not our theme is blue Okay.
Dev worked in a water park?
Maybe.
Oh, that sucks.
I just wasted $5.
Oh, well.
Okay.
Alright, we've restocked.
We cleaned everything.
Um.
Spread love with the water gun.
Road to second star.
And then clean smelly guests with water gun.
Well, they have to, like, show up, no?
I can't just spray a guy.
What about you, Braylon?
Where are you?
Paint these stairs?
We'll get there.
Oh, wow.
It doesn't extend all the way to the top.
Horrible.
Okay, let's go to sleep.
Oh.
A flock of seagulls are in the sky.
I hear them.
Okay.
Is this... bad for business?
Um...
Okay?
Alright, Braylin, let's... let's get this bread!
Yeah, yeah!
The park is open!
Wait, the seagulls poop?
They're not gonna blame me for that, though, right?
Am I gonna get sued for...
For...
The Seagulls are leaving a mess!
Oh!
Oh, it's like super intense amounts of poop.
Oh my gosh!
I just...
I hear it non-stop!
What is happening?
They're getting louder!
Grab the janitor.
I don't think I have enough points yet!
They're even hiding it in the stairs!
Oh, this is gonna suck!
Wait, I think they're gone.
I don't hear them anymore.
Braylon screwed up the order on a visitor.
Braylon.
Braylon, I have too much to worry about here, buddy!
You gotta hold your own!
You gotta hold your own.
Lock in, Braylon.
The day just started.
So they like being spread?
Okay, I got one person.
Two people?
Yeah!
Okay, we're working towards that two stars, baby.
Yeah, Phoenix!
Yeah!
Yeah, wet t-shirt content!
Oh!
Where are you going?
Woohoo!
Yeah!
Wait, oh, that's what I was gonna do too.
Oh, we got the basic showers!
What we can do is we can destroy...
How do I delete it?
Okay, hold on.
Quit.
What we're gonna do is we're going to add more...
Oh, I have some decorations.
Where are the seeds?
Here we go.
We need to add more seats for people because remember people were getting tired.
Upgrades.
Yeah, yeah.
And then we get more research points too with that.
Okay, hold on.
Now.
I can't get the janitorial staff until we're the two stars.
Okay.
Two stars is a must.
Everybody.
Oh.
Ooh.
Yay!
Yeah!
You get spread.
You can spread.
Don't get up.
Don't move.
Okay, you're fine.
Oh, just kidding.
Yeah, you had already fallen.
Okay, so now I'm going to demolish this.
Don't use it.
Oops.
My bad.
Ivory is waiting.
Don't use that.
Sorry.
Excuse me, Manny.
Why she couldn't wait two seconds?
Hot dog.
Add both.
Yes.
Add ketchup.
Best date ever.
So true.
Hello.
Add mustard.
Woohoo.
Yes.
Oh.
Add both.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, indeed.
Are you having fun?
Do you like it?
Okay.
We just got that achievement.
Somebody is drowning.
Oh, there's two people drowning.
I need to save one!
Two people are drowning and I can only save one!
Oh my gosh.
Um...
Demi, hold on!
Don't run off with that, Phoenix.
Phoenix, please.
Phoenix.
Please.
Please, I need this.
You can...
You pick it!
Oh my gosh.
We almost didn't get to save both of them.
Well, we did.
We saved both of them.
Poop?
Wait, where's Poop?
Where was Poop at?
In here?
I don't see any.
This is so stressful.
Right?
Oh, hello.
Um, add mustard.
The bin?
Oh, I got it.
I'll get it.
Sorry, ma'am.
Near the filter.
Oh, that's a gun.
Near the filter, a poop?
Oh, this bird poop!
Can people...
slip on the poop, I wonder.
This is trash.
We got it.
I gotta move this water gun or else I'm gonna forever.
Actually, I'll hold on to it just in case more smelly people come because we need to get three more smellies.
Three more stinky nasties.
I think we should put, like, a sign that says, careful.
You might slip.
Oh, hello.
Add both.
There you go.
We're gonna have to go buy more hot dogs soon.
Someone just slept?
Am I crazy?
Am I hearing things?
Oh.
Sorry.
This is Power Wash Simulator.
I thought it was gonna be more like Power Wash Simulator, but it is actual chaos.
My Yoshi is a menace.
I, I'm doing my best here.
Um, let's start repairing things before they go out of craziness.
Everything's gonna start breaking soon.
And then people are gonna start breaking their backs and suing me, even though it says out of, out of commission, you know?
You're sleeping.
Yeah, Power Wash, I thought I was going to be like, oh, yeah, we'll chill and I'll talk.
Braylon is too tired.
Okay, now we have to...
Ew.
What do you want?
Plane.
Okay, we got to be on the lookout for...
Oh, for the people.
Hello.
Adult.
It's been forever since we've done this, huh?
Oh, that's Brailin.
Okay, I thought that was somebody breaking in.
Drowning?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, thank you guys.
Where's the, where's the?
Thank goodness indeed, huh?
Yep.
It's a good thing Chat was here.
Oh, oh.
First you drown, and then you...
Oh, sorry.
Sputtle's got a vendetta.
Oh.
Ray, are you good?
If only there was a bin right here, idiot.
Hello?
You are a bastard!
Yeah, you deserve that.
You deserve that!
Come back to me.
We helped him get out of the park faster.
Waiting for a hot dog.
Girl!
Damn, Sadie, okay.
She wants me.
Yes?
Add ketchup.
That's only 4 p.m.
Oh, golly!
More trash!
Oh, Braylin's back, thank God.
Okay.
We're gonna put our tiny trash bag right there.
Everybody remember it.
Hello, bye-bye.
Thank you.
Easy toes!
Thank you so much for the time.
You have to thank you!
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Everybody, watch out.
Watch your toes.
Watch your feet.
Watch your everything.
Watch.
Oh, let me go grab my trash bag.
Thank goodness we have bigger pockets now, huh?
Who kicked us in there?
Wait.
Eh?
Huh.
Why didn't...
Oh.
Oh, hello?
Catch up.
Okay.
Trash.
Probably from you, the culprit, right there in front of me.
Let me trash.
Let me poo.
Ten bucks for a hot dog.
Yeah, what of it, huh?
I'm trying to run a business here.
It ain't easy.
You see how hard I'm working right now?
I'm working my butt off.
No rest when you're dead.
None at all.
Uh-oh.
Life ring!
I am your hero.
You're welcome.
I love you.
Oh, sorry.
Another one drowning?
I'm safe now.
When can we get...
I can't wait until this turns into like an idle game or like, you know, IDLE, like an idle work game where I just run around and do a little bit of stuff, but everyone else does everything for me, you know?
I can't... What does that... What does that happen?
Panicking.
Don't do that!
Oh, thank goodness.
The day is over.
Okay.
My income was...
Not a lot.
I see something in the water, you do?
Ugh.
We can finally fix everything.
All this stuff.
We need to start getting upgrades that don't, like, need fixing every two seconds, you know.
Floor injuries?
Nothing.
No issues.
Second star for Repair Man.
But Repair Man, was that two stars or was it just janitor?
We'll go check.
If you guys want to feel stressed while playing video games.
Not relaxed at all.
I would recommend this.
Repair was only one.
Okay, okay.
We'll get that guy.
Let's go get him right in there.
wait handyman staff wait I I did get this one wait maybe I have to buy them ah I have to hire them
they're expensive
charge your tablet
isn't it me or did Braylon's efficiency go down
Do you have enough income?
I don't think so.
Get the cheapest guy.
Lorenzo.
Well, we can test him for one day.
And see if he's worth it, you know.
We'll test him for one day.
And it might be like, he sucks.
And...
And he doesn't do anything, you know?
And if that's the case...
Um...
Then we can fire him after one day.
I think I got all the chairs.
He'll...
Then we give him the hammer.
And he'll get the hammer no matter what.
Okay.
janitor over worker yeah but i still have to get more smelly people i still need three more smellies to come to my park to stink up the place before i can uh even get the janitor i think we'll have enough for both oh yeah well i would still have to hire the janitor home
let's do um basic slide we could like upgrade a bunch of stuff know any smellies in chat i think we could get some like slides and pools and upgrade everything overnight new pool i can get tips
hmm i
don't think i need walk speed right now maybe if i because We're kind of zooming around.
I think maybe Waxbeard would be better once we increase the size of the park, I'd say.
How do I delete you?
I think I just have to destroy it, huh?
With the sledgehammer?
Oh.
Oh, it's fire.
Oh, I do get money back for that.
Wait, that's huge.
Huge!
Okay, so we get money back from destroying things.
Is it the...
Is it the same amount?
I'm not quite sure, honestly.
Let's see how much it is.
For the slide.
Or for this.
It's 30...
Okay, so it's a partial rebound.
What?
Oh, we can make shapes!
Oh, circle pool!
That's exciting.
That's exciting very much so.
Wait, I'm...
I don't want...
Here, we'll put this...
The repair thing, like...
On this side.
Okay.
Spherical.
Oh!
Wow.
And then we're going to...
move this.
I'm making myself a genuine park, everybody.
This is gonna be nice.
Wait, there's like a snap feature.
Here we go.
There we go.
Yeah.
Wait, I want you closer.
Nice.
Get close with your shower mate.
And then we'll get a pool or a diving board.
Diving board.
Okay.
Slides.
Do I have...
I'm trying to think.
Can I move myself?
Uh...
Here?
Wait, what did I do with the sledgehammer?
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Yeah.
No.
Hammer.
It's a regular hammer.
I don't think I upgraded the slides.
Okay.
Now my $10, um...
Now my $10 hot dog is justified.
Okay, let's go back into here.
Wait, move again.
Like move over here.
Okay.
Okay, pools.
Rectangular pool.
Whoa, it's so big though.
Let's do funky shapes instead.
Wow.
I'm gonna build a rocket.
Where the wisps trying to shower together at.
We'll do like this.
Wow, it's so like...
Wow, fancy.
It's like a hat.
Oh, D!
Wait, you're right.
Just like the game.
Kojima does it again.
Oh, wait.
I gotta move all these.
One moment, please.
Oh, D.
Uncle Jumbo does it again.
Up here.
D.
Oh, D.
Just like that.
Oh, wait.
Better.
Better one.
There we go.
Another diving ward.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We don't have a lot of money left.
But.
This might save us some grief.
You know?
This might save us.
The fact that we aren't hiring someone.
My eyes!
It's really fancy.
It's fancy, isn't it?
And then we go back and there was like some decoration that we could get.
Ooh, planter.
How much are you?
Free?
Okay.
Nice.
What is this?
A fountain?
Wait, can I put this in the pool?
Make it like a little nipple.
Okay, awesome.
Oh, oops.
I'm getting really excited about my park.
I could have made it two boobs.
Missed opportunity.
My bad.
I'm trying to like keep them all kind of close-ish so I don't have to go running around.
You know what I mean?
I could like, can I rotate?
Oh, I can.
Okay, there we go.
We get your relaxation out of the way.
All right.
Now it doesn't...
No slide?
Oh, yeah.
We can do a slide.
We can still do the slide.
Don't worry.
It's gonna happen.
I just don't know where to put it.
Okay, hold
on.
Don't say rip slide just yet.
Um...
It looks like a Q.
QD.
Where should I put it?
The pool spells out OD.
What kind of pool party is this?
It's a...
Pool party.
Wait.
I didn't mean to do that.
We're gonna move some stuff.
Okay.
I'm, like, really low...
Wait.
I'm... I'm getting...
I'm... Low on room.
Words are really hard, okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna put this trash can here, too, since people just don't know how to get to it.
Low on money.
Okay, this is what we'll do.
Wait, I saw it.
green color I saw it
we'll have to invest in a better slide later one that tor turns and twists is it because of the what's it called I wonder the it might be because of the the filter please
Please.
These people can line up.
Oh my god.
No fun allowed.
No!
What else can we do?
We sold out.
We sold.
We were...
We went too fancy.
You know?
Our values.
We forgot what was important, what the children loved.
Wait, why can't I move the fountain?
Okay, it's just gonna be a lopsided boob, okay?
It's very common.
Why can't I move it?
Come on, let me try and get in nice and close.
No, please!
Oh, no!
The fountain!
Right into the fountain.
Yeah, you'll just face plant straight into like the...
Straight into the metal pipes.
How exciting.
And liberating.
Everybody loves that feeling.
Okay, I'm going to try and move the pool.
So that we can then...
Grab the fountain.
I saw it.
I saw the light.
At last I see the light.
Okay.
You move you.
All right.
Back to ODing.
I went the wrong way.
And...
Straight in the middle.
Okay.
Okay!
We managed that!
We did that.
Team?
How are we feeling?
Look how nice our place looks now.
Fish.
This is fancy.
And they're bigger pools.
Well, one of them is.
Okay.
All right, Braylin, good night.
See you tomorrow.
Oh, I forgot to build my stuff.
Oops.
Oh, here we go.
Build slide.
And wasn't there something else I forgot to build?
Or am I crazy?
I thought I said build two things.
I guess not.
I don't see anything else.
Yahoo!
Braylin, it's going to be a great day.
It's going to be a great day.
day buddy i'm broke yeah but we're gonna make huge bucks today i'm not gonna hit a single person and nobody will die so we won't pay any fines already
and there's no birds shitting up the place everything is clean and almost new
oh i'm getting way too ahead of myself
Hey Amito, I'm a newer wisp.
Hi, I've been watching some old vibes.
Can you explain what a zoom beanie is?
A zoom beanie is a guy.
A little guy.
He goes on a great great adventure.
A great journey.
Wow, look at our line.
Are you gonna are you gonna get the Braylon?
Yeah, she likes it.
She doesn't...
You're out of water park, man.
Don't act like you're better than me.
Whoa.
Yeah, yeah!
This kind of makes me want to go to the pool.
I'm not gonna lie.
This makes me want to go to the pool, too.
Oh, sorry, Grace.
You okay?
She, like, whined about it.
So cute.
She was like, Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Raylan screwed up.
Raylan!
No, sir, please.
Take our sincerest apologies.
You want to go to the bike park.
No, you don't say boring.
New research point.
You want to come to my park.
Shit.
Everyone's a hater.
Did I get you already?
Best day ever.
Ivory's waiting for a hot dog?
Anika's drowning?
Hot dog.
Did Ivory stalk a kid?
Kind of.
Did someone steal one?
Ivory got her hot dog and was just like...
Not today.
It hit her immediately.
The dogs will do that to you.
I saw the trash there.
I'm getting my trash bag.
Don't worry about it.
Don't complain.
Oh, Ivory, are you okay?
What did you do, girl?
How did you fall?
Like, actually.
Can I get some smelly people in here, please?
Oh.
Add both.
I wish I could afford, like, uh, you know.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You're safe now.
Who are you?
Indiana Jones!
Is my park not safe?
Why did she scream like that?
Did you see him?
He went, he jumped out backwards from one pool and straight into the other one.
Uh-oh, please don't get up.
Don't move.
Do not move your feet.
Thank you.
I am concerned.
No, no, no!
Oh, thank God.
If you're hungry, come over to Hot Dog.
It's only $10.
Why is everybody in one?
It's just a catastrophe.
No, stop!
Why is everybody only in one pool?
Curious.
Come on.
Why though?
It's a massacre.
Hello.
Plane.
I like that.
Do they not like the fountain?
I wonder...
Kobe!
Oh, hot dog.
Hello?
Plane.
Add both.
See, I like it when they ask for a plane because it's way less, uh, oh shoot.
Oh my god!
COVID!
Whoa!
Oh, she's already She got COVID Oh, she got COVID Oh, I got COVID Oh, my God Oh, my God, it's a massacre Oh, my God, oh, my God Oh, my God, oh, my God Please let me Please let me Leave it Oh, but not
the COVID, COVID, COVID I don't have any Sorry, we're sold out
What is this circling?
Oh, the restock thing.
Don't walk there.
Damn it.
You're just gonna have to move.
You're just gonna have to let it happen.
Some people are like, I think I ruined our park, everybody.
I think we've...
I think we made it worse.
Just let it happen.
Okay.
It's a madhouse.
It really is.
It really is an absolute madhouse.
Oh my gosh.
People are just sleeping on the ground.
My pools are getting dirty.
And more wear and tear.
The pool contractors should be sued for not making drains.
For real though.
I'm surprised I didn't smack that lady.
I'm going to get rid of the fountain.
I don't think people like the fountain.
Raiden, what are you doing?
Are you on break?
Okay, nobody's here.
Uh, plane?
Yeah.
I see him drowning.
I'll get him.
Thank you.
Ow, was a close one.
Oh, me too.
Man.
Everybody down!
Hello!
Slide pass!
Oh, Braden, you get me every time!
Dude, I can't see!
I- I- please!
I gotta get that lady.
She just- I gotta kill her.
Look at her little evil emoji.
Yeah, you slide there.
Have 100 visitors slip on puddles.
Me too!
Oh my gosh.
Whambo combo, baby.
Okay.
Let's repair these.
Ah, everybody.
This is the most stressful stimulator game I think I've ever played in my entire afterlife.
Waiting for a hot dog.
Okay, one moment, please.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, don't do it!
Okay.
I'm on my way!
What would you like?
Thank you.
Did I say stimulator?
I'm saying simulator, you guys.
Come on!
Get your heads out of the pool!
Get your heads out of the chlorine!
I'm sick!
I have a list!
I don't know!
Everything's wrong with me!
Are you not stimulated?
Rusty Loungeer is broken.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, that was still small.
Dang it.
I messed up.
Add ketchup.
I think I'm heavily stimulated.
I'm not going to lie.
What's broken?
Which one's broken?
Get off of it.
A mirror.
Please move.
Thank you.
You're not wrong.
It's very stimulating.
Yes.
I'm running around.
doing everything that I possibly can.
I need more stinky people.
How do I get more smelly guests?
Maybe I gotta get rid of the showers.
I keep...
I'm getting...
Oh, clean 100...
Oh, no, sorry.
500 attractions.
Wow.
Someone's panicking on the diving board.
Yeah, maybe if I get rid of the showers, they'll be more stinky.
Oh, sorry.
Please.
I don't want to be a business owner anymore.
I hate being my own boss.
An actual maid.
I'm here.
You are here.
Oh, hello.
Oh.
6 p.m.
Wait, we are...
We made a lot of money.
We actually made a good amount.
484?
Okay.
But still no smelly people to
cause the smellmageddon.
Okay, what we're gonna do is this.
I'm gonna first do it like that.
So there's not so much, you know, everything happening all at once.
I wish I could move this.
Yeah, so much foot traffic, exactly.
I wish, though, I could get the fountain.
I don't think they like it.
I don't think they like the fountain.
Oh, there we go.
We'll move it just like to be a decoration.
Oh wait, we were doing this way.
Here we go.
Okay.
That should be better.
This should be sufficient.
I don't think it's the fountain.
You don't think so?
You don't think they'd be so excited about the fountain?
Why are puddles a problem out of a water park?
Alright, we'll see if people now go into this pool.
If we move it around a little bit.
Because just people were sliding and jumping, but they weren't really swimming.
You know?
We gotta really get our hot dogs.
Sorry.
A potential customer.
Alright.
I could get a lemonade stand.
Do we want another thing to manage?
People will pay more.
Paymore is big Wait, hammer upgrade Construction time reduced Does that also include Repair time?
Cleanliness management Things stay cleaner for longer Makes puddles easier to spot We could do the tips You know what, we'll do tips because that seems like Passive income, though And then unlocks a stand with inflatable life rings.
Basic slide.
A jukebox!
My $10 lemonade.
Hell yeah.
Would you drink it?
No.
Right now I'm kind of...
Okay, I'm gonna get the ticket price.
That's also more money.
With money, we can do anything that we want.
That's the reality.
I only have $10.
It used to be a quarter.
At what park?
At what theme park?
We could change out our slide.
Fun with some gravity involved.
I'm going to get some slides.
What we're going to do is we're going to get rid of this ugly thing.
I hate it.
One lemonade, please.
Coming right up.
Goop, goop, goop.
Get rid of this thing.
Wait.
I gotta get rid of it myself.
Sledgehammer.
Even though I just bought it.
I don't care.
Okay.
Now, what kind of slides we...
See, you guys?
This is the future.
This is what the people want.
I gotta move out of the way.
Out with the old and with the new, exactly.
That's so fun.
We got ourselves a swirly slide.
And we're gonna even do another slide over here.
Because we love our customers.
Somehow.
It might be, like, super tough.
Well, you know what?
Two slides.
They can...
They'll just...
They'll look out for each other.
Whoa, yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Woo!
Fantastic.
What's that, dude?
Keep forgetting.
to clean stuff.
The party pool, baby!
Oh my gosh.
My showers are horrible at the moment.
Wait, but...
I want to get rid of them, but I don't think I can.
I won't, I won't, like, make the money back, you know?
We only get some of the money back.
What should we do?
One big change a day.
I think that's reasonable.
I think that's pretty reasonable.
One big change a day.
We haven't hired any more staff yet.
Besides...
Benny.
It's...
It's all me.
Alright, I think that's everything.
Oh wait, just kidding.
Cashier staff is goaded.
I agree.
Not having to sell tickets.
Takes a load off my shoulders.
I think once maybe we see how much money we make after the ticket increase.
And tips.
We might be able to then acquire on second hand.
You know?
All right, praying for smellies today.
I mean tomorrow.
Smelly people are welcome at my theme park.
In fact, smelly people are encouraged at my theme park.
I'll take every smelly person.
And all are welcome.
Okay.
I'm smelly.
Let's get some smellies in here.
Can we get a smelly counter?
Okay.
We need three smellies.
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh, you're already coming?
Okay, you're all right.
Oh, whoa.
Wait, wait, wait, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you.
You, you, you, you, you, you, you, you.
Yeah, you, you, you, you, you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you coming?
You.
All right.
Get out of my park.
I like when they have the little evil emoji.
Stealth attack Smellie!
Smellie Smellie!
Oh, Estelle!
I love you!
My stinky girl!
Okay, go Go enjoy the park.
We got a stinker!
Alright, come on!
Indy, I know you're gonna be wreaking.
I know you're gonna be disgusting.
Come on, Indy.
Don't disab- Yay!
Okay, oops, sorry, too much.
Ah, stinky, stinky!
Thirsty guests equals easy money.
Sometimes guests get thirsty fast and nothing hits the spot like a good coke cup of lemonade.
Set up a lemonade stand and turn thirst into profit one sip at a time.
Oh, the next star, so two and a half.
Wait.
We're not to two stars yet?
We're being forced.
Are you kidding me right now?
We're being forced against my will to do lemonade?
What would it be under?
Utility?
There we are.
Uh.
Uh, where are the...
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, I thought I already had people.
I was about to scream.
I was about to lose it.
Uh, I don't have anywhere to put it.
Oh.
Where are you
at?
Oh, hi Estelle.
Add ketchup.
Anything for you, my darling.
Right next to the hot dog?
I tried.
Let me try again.
Maybe we face it like this way?
No.
Oh, it has to be a little crooked, but it'll work.
I think it'll work.
It's gotta be a little crooked, but that's okay.
Everyone's enjoying their time.
Nobody is... This is good so far, actually.
Stinky!
We don't need stinky.
Okay, too many stinkies.
Lemonade add eyes.
Wait.
Lemonade?
Add the... Wait, lemonade?
How do I do this?
Restock the lemonade.
I just got the lemonade.
Okay.
Rusty lounger is dirty!
Oh, lemons.
When life gives you lemons.
Uh-oh, we got thirsty people.
I want lemonade, add ice, add lemon.
Okay.
Lemonade, add ice, add lemon.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Life bought me lemons.
Oh, it's been a minute since we've had to wipe up dirt.
People are actually being a little clean.
Oh, sorry, Sadie.
I almost hit you, girl.
Oh, my gosh.
We got a stinker.
Where's my gun?
Oh, there.
Oh, sorry, Estelle.
Oh, I deserve that.
Don't do it.
People are waiting for lemonade.
Hello?
Lemonade?
Add ice?
Add lemon?
Dojo?
Plain?
Mustard?
Dojo?
I saw a stinky.
I think the stinky is gone.
Who gets a plain hot dog?
Hey, I'm not complaining.
Oh my gosh.
it's easier for me plane is great plane is great we're not judging what did I oh
am I tiny yeah I can barely do anything you guys this is insanity oh my gosh hello lemonade add lemon those y'all add mustard Dojo?
Lemonade?
And lemon?
Dojo?
We need more stuff.
I know, but I need more body.
Oh, oops, I did it again.
Oops, I...
Good enough.
Oh!
Oh, somebody's dying!
Somebody's drowning!
I don't know where the...
Uh-oh.
I don't know where my floaty is.
I don't know where the floaty is.
Where's the floaty?
He's dying and I'm laughing and I'm picking up trash.
Lane just...
Just stand up, dude.
It's...
It's really...
It's not even that...
Deep.
Don't worry about it.
Like a five-year-old.
injured.
I received a fine.
Where's my floaty at?
Guys, I actually don't know where it is.
Yes, waited too long for... If I, like... Oh, okay.
If I, like, um...
Oh, okay.
I can just re-grab it here.
Alright.
I'm trying my best.
Med kit.
Jason is waiting for some lemonade.
Hello?
Lemonade?
Add ice, add lemon.
Jojo?
Hello?
Add both.
They never say please, you know.
Or anything like that.
Oh!
Oh, where did I put the floaty?
I lost it again.
I lost it again!
You're fine!
You'll live this time!
Oh, there's the medic.
Everything's fine!
Oh my gosh, a stinky in my pool.
I need more pockets.
Yeah, you do need a shower.
Okay, this is actually becoming the real, like, pool experience where it just becomes gross.
Maybe all water parks are just being, you know, managed by one minto, okay?
Beat.
That could just be the case.
Very realistic.
Exactly.
Okay.
lady lady don't do it oh i got it just in time yes waited too long for hot dogs sorry we're close one freaky ghost trying our best guys i'm doing everything i think this game would kind of be nice if you're like just going through the motions of it all you know you're not even like thinking you're just like you're just It's like,
okay, now I go clean this thing.
Okay, now I go repair this thing.
Okay, now I go serve this person.
It's my birthday!
Aerie Blue!
Happy birthday!
One moment.
Lemon.
Add mustard.
Yo-yo.
Is there co-op?
That's a good question, actually.
I do not know.
I feel like...
I feel like this is the perfect game for multiplayer, no?
Lemonade.
Oh my gosh, and you're gross!
Hello, lemonade?
At least the lemonade lasts a while.
Oh, hot dog?
Yes?
Plane?
Yep.
Thank you everyone for the birthday wishes!
Happy birthday, Harry!
Sorry, this game is like insane.
What are you saying here?
Imagine it like overcooked.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do too.
Wait, wait, wait.
Alright.
Boy, boy.
Actually, the pools last a lot longer though.
This water park is full of aliens.
Just saw humans swimming and didn't quite understand.
That's how I feel about any sort of like rag dolly, kind of, you know.
I've repaired 500 attractions.
Okay, I don't think that's...
Like, I think that's kind of gross.
I don't think you want to lay on it.
I think you will definitely get some sort of disease laying on this thing.
Hey!
Okay.
Hot dog.
Yes, ma'am!
Add ketchup!
There you go.
Okay.
All right.
Our showers are kind of gross, but what can you do?
What's the one?
Tetris.
I think you would get Tetris on our...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, Kaysen.
So sorry.
Please watch out.
Oh, the day is over!
Thank God!
Sorry, I just clicked out of the stats because I wanted to repair these.
Oh.
We made it, team.
Oh, I didn't get the second star because we didn't get two!
So eight lemonades.
Oh, I tried.
I tried.
And you know, people aren't pooping in the pool anymore, so...
That's also huge.
Oh!
Slowly but surely, we're becoming a more civilized society.
The pool girl at this park is super cute.
You don't think she's, like, running herself ragged?
Really?
I think it might be time to get new bathrooms.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
Big stretch after such a long day of work.
Gosh, got...
Hey buddy.
Pool's closed.
Pool's closed, buddy.
Pool's closed!
This is what happens after hours.
You know, when you were a kid and you ever wanted to stay longer at a store, like hide.
Like at a theme park or wherever.
This is what would happen to you.
So don't trespass.
Go away, Ray.
Oh, I almost missed this puddle.
How?
A free massage.
Okay, I think we should...
I think it's time to get a new look.
You know what?
Yeah.
I think we cleaned everything.
Let's restock our lemons and our hot dogs and we'll be good to go.
How much money?
Okay, 900.
I don't know, you guys.
What do you think?
You think it's enough to hire a person?
Milos, welcome to Mambusha Banco!
Yeah?
Okay.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to hire someone tomorrow.
But I'm also going to upgrade our toilets.
I think...
I don't know actually if we got...
Oh, basic toilets.
Here we go.
And I'm going to do the make sure...
things longer, clean the air for longer.
Okay.
So then we destroy this.
Haia!
And this.
Because I've noticed people are going into the bathrooms and coming out stinky.
And coming out gross and nasty.
So if we can prevent that, I think it would be good.
I'm at work, but I feel like you're working hard in this I am.
Nice.
Okay, let's go to sleep.
Good night, Braylon.
Minto people are just gross.
I agree.
Trust me, I agree.
Our park is coming up great, I think.
Okay, I think I fixed it and cleaned everything, so let's start the day, baby.
Sad thing is $40 lemons doesn't seem that crazy.
in today's economy.
I really don't need the sledgehammer, do I?
But it's fine.
We're in a tent because, you know, our livelihood went to the park.
We don't need...
We're not...
I have a hammer.
Just because I got rid of...
My sledgehammer doesn't mean I don't have a hammer.
for you, Georgina.
I had to be careful.
I regret everything!
Murder is okay.
They're breaking, they're trespassing.
Yeah, you had a human shield.
What a tricky guy.
Ooh, okay, girl.
Okay, Nova.
With the tricks.
Yes.
Yes, you want lemonade?
Yeah, yeah.
Lemonade at ice.
Yeah.
Okay, just one more.
Yeah?
Plane?
I think I see a cheater.
So clean.
She's enjoying that, I doubt.
Yeah, girl.
Get it.
Yeah, girl, get it.
Braylon, you're doing a great job, buddy.
I'm going to go pass out some flyers.
We need more of my...
Hey there, you.
No?
Did I offend?
Where are all the townspeople?
You, you, you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What about you?
Wait, why are you booing?
What did you do, Braylon?
This rocks!
She says that she like completely face plants, knows, dies.
into the water add lemon what oh did I miss it no oh you're back add ice and add lemon bigger trash bags okay unlock park size level one what which one Wait, I actually don't know what you're asking, is it?
Unlock the Park Size Level 1 Research.
Decoration?
Oh, this one!
Oh, I need both.
Style equals profit.
Okay, baby.
Park Size Level...
This is to get us to Level 2, everybody.
Build a lounger with...
with one prestige.
Uh-oh.
You're okay.
I've spent a whole lot of money?
Whoa!
Um...
Oh my gosh!
Our park is going crazy!
Please, can I please get...
Okay, we need to get loungers.
We have a lot more land.
Oh, hello.
Sorry.
What do you want?
Hello?
I want lemonade.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Oh, that's right.
I'm gonna hire somebody now.
We're gonna hire people.
Oh, that's right.
I do this here.
Madden.
John Madden.
Hire.
Get in here.
I've reached my staff limit.
Okay.
is going to come in here.
Wait, can I only have one person?
I can only have one person.
Okay, oh.
I just watched that garbage go into the sky?
Please!
Not good, not good!
Wait, why can I only have one staff member?
Are you kidding me?
now?
Lemonade, add lemon.
No, gel.
Lemonade, lemon, ice.
Add both.
Lemon ice.
Ketchup.
Doesn't make me hungry.
Not gonna lie.
My leg!
They get upset when they like slip.
They're like, I don't, you know what?
I don't want the lemonade anymore.
They're like little babies.
Add mustard.
Plane.
No bin inside.
No, no, no.
There is a bin.
I promise you.
People have been littering less, though.
Someone's waiting for a hot dog.
Hold on.
I gotta mop these puddles, baby.
I gotta do it.
I gotta be swift.
Oh.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, oh.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I don't think they ordered that service.
Mustard.
Add lemon.
Special.
That's for after hours.
I'm so sorry!
Please forgive me!
Whoa, that was a close one.
Oh, oh, please.
Everybody?
Nope, don't walk here.
I can do that.
Uh-huh.
Prepare low jumper.
Lemon.
Ice.
Low jumper.
Oh, this one.
Are we... Are we... Are we... Are we feeling... Are we feeling good, team?
How are we feeling?
That was close.
I almost just whacked that man.
I almost just took him out.
New research point.
Let's go.
I'm feeling it, Mr. Crabs.
Woo!
That was close.
Nova's waiting on a hot dog.
Nova, you've been here all day, girl.
We'll home.
Okay.
Are these organic lemons?
Make it stop!
I was trying!
Oops.
I don't even recognize my own character now that we've changed.
Uh-oh, somebody's drowning?
Um... Floody is right there, girl.
You definitely could have done that yourself.
Okay.
Oh, hot dogs.
Hello?
Add ketchup?
This guy is becoming golden.
Oh, no!
I'm out of dogs.
Who have I?
Who has time to go out and, like, pass out flyers, you know?
Unless you have the worst park in the world and nobody's coming over, but...
lane perfect yes baby let add ice lemonade easy peasy lemonade sand needs to be restocked okay let's go we're running we're running we're running we're running it's called hustling i don't think i even need to do ads i'm like going insane oh style over here
Oh no, COVID.
COVID, COVID.
Get out of the pool!
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, he listened to me.
Oh, just...
Oh, no!
I need anti...
Oh, somebody's drowning?
Ooh.
Oh, you.
Oh.
He could use such a urgency.
Will I make it here yes baby let's go add mustard don't mind me just handling the trash just then okay buddy add mustard
yeah i i definitely handled the trash but it's like hypogenic trash so don't even concern your pretty little head about it vegas never sleeps
more trash on the ground who's doing this oh my goodness this one's disgusting
yeah and don't mind that i'm also sick and handling your food don't even think about that kind of those are just small details
lemon there you go what toilet um wrong way lady why are you dropping all your trash on the ground oh my god he dropped the trash on the ground and then got mad about it sending again since chat died during half-life two you want some batman joker b arkham games got you covered no way someone just no wasn't that lady add both no stinking way oh the day is over Oh,
thank God.
The day is over.
Oh, oh, thank God.
Poor service.
Guys, we did it.
We did it.
We did it somehow.
Time to check out the new space.
I know it.
Oh, my goodness.
This is awesome.
Let's repair everything.
I might just get rid of the ugly...
I think we have better...
What's it called now that we can get?
Loungeers, so I'll probably get rid of all of these.
No way one hired hand is the game's final limit.
I don't know.
I didn't look in the...
There's gotta be...
Oh wait, okay, here's the basic loungers.
Okay, good.
you know what i'm just gonna get both of these let's go okay now we have everything for park the puddle highlight i feel like i see them i think it's okay the increased walking speed might be better now what do i need more for oh the loungers okay so we need the loungers to get higher rating where's my sledgehammer Hello.
Hello.
I hate these.
I'm so happy to destroy them.
Yes.
Get rid of them.
Yeah, we're gonna do it right now.
I almost broke this instead.
Let's clean everything up as well.
Yeah, they look so bad.
and our park is looking so nice now.
I don't want to...
I don't want to have OD land be really great.
This is mop poop.
I think this is graffiti?
Poop?
Whoa.
I don't think that's...
Demolition daydream.
I went to Minto Park and all I got was 10.
This Rona and HEP-E.
So a park employee tripped me over and then landed on me.
That was a special service.
Don't act like you hated it.
Don't act like that, babe.
Come on, girl.
Come on, sweetie.
Don't act like that, babe.
Come on.
I'm being a toxic boyfriend.
Being toxic.
Wow, this area is crazy.
Oh, we were once this young.
Who taught you to be like this?
TV.
I watched Degrassi one time.
Actually, only...
I never really watched Degrassi.
There was one point, though, I really got into Gilmore Girl.
I binged that when I lived in Japan I binged a gossip girl and Gilmore girls oh and then I also I really like I was really into pretty little liars one time I was flying on the plane and they had a couple episodes and I was like whoa wait this is kind of mysterious and spooky and then I watched the rest of the show and I was like always kind of cringe but did I watch the whole thing yeah I did.
I watched the whole thing.
PLLO Lordy.
If you know, you know.
But it's funny because the Pretty Little Liars um uh audiobook is voiced by a really like popular English voice actress.
I can't remember her name right now.
But I once met her and I was like, oh my gosh, Pretty Little Liars!
And she was like, What the hell?
I heard that the new no tax on tips policy includes donations to streamers.
Oh, does it?
Thank you.
I think Doki Bird wrote her dissertation on that show.
Pretty Little Liars?
It's literally...
It's exactly what FNAF did.
Where people guessed what was going on and they would like...
Be like...
actually you think you know what's going on but you actually don't know what's going on even though people guessed correctly and so the show became like an absolute an absolute mess because the team was just so like upset that people were guessing what was actually happening oh
riverdale did the same thing yeah i went completely off the rails people would be like oh we think so basically liars is about a group of girls and one summer they they get together and one of the girls Allison de Laurentes she goes missing in the middle of the night and she goes missing and the girls are like oh my gosh our friend but she's kind of like not a nice girl so they're a little relieved you know and then they're at her funeral because they're like alison's never coming back when when they're at their funeral and they all get a text from this person named a who's just like i know what you did last summer i know you killed me or whatever you know and so the story the the mystery is just like oh my gosh is a alison Is A someone else?
Is A...
Like, and if A is someone else, how do they know...
What the girlies did, you know?
It's so stupid and I love it.
It's...
And, you know, I'm like a sucker for...
I was like, you know what?
It's a little teen drama.
I don't care.
I'm a sucker for a mystery.
But it just went craziness.
Cassandra Lee Morris!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, I thought it was her, but I could not remember.
why are they friends with her if they hate her I don't know sometimes teenage girls are weird they're weird
but yeah and so like and then shenanigans ensue and then the girls like almost die and there's like a student teacher relationship I was like this is for Teenagers?
This is for...
This is for kids?
I was like, whoa!
Teenage girls are weird.
Source me, a teenage girl.
Yeah!
Well, it's really high school girls.
Yo, Blue Archive?
Yeah.
Like one of the girls, she goes to like a bar and then hooks up with the girls.
guy and then the guy ends up being her teacher and you're like uh oh spaghetti oh okay we're getting the lounges that's right so yeah i like i watched i was like when i watched the show it was like i don't remember what season it was but it was like in the middle of the season probably season one I think it was it was like in the middle of the season I was like I had no idea what was going on but I was like oh my gosh a mystery and I was flying back from Japan and so then I um got home and I was so jet lagged that I just watched pretty much the whole show while I recovered from jet lag I was like I was like yeah baby
trash cans!
Yippee!
Okay.
We're gonna make more use of this extra space we got going on, baby.
Nobody will be littering on our watch.
We'll put one even right here.
Have you seen Shameless?
I haven't even heard of that.
When I was a teenager, I was watching Bleach and Deathmelt.
I think the kids are still watching that, no?
I don't know, actually.
No, they're watching, like, My Hero and...
But, I mean, they're watching things that are of similar substance, probably.
You know?
Trashy TV.
Yeah, they're watching JJK!
Oh, yeah, they're watching Jujutsukaisen, Demon Slayer.
Okay, so we need five lounges.
I'm gonna put all of them over here.
If people are tired, they gotta work for it.
Five, right next to the dumpster.
Smelly, smelly, smelly.
Oh yeah.
I don't like trash TV.
Though, I have watched my fair share of things.
Like, uh...
I have a friend, she's super into those shows, like, Love Island or whatever.
I don't watch any of that.
But I did, my roommate, she and I would watch a 90-day fianc together.
I don't watch it anymore.
Okay, but what about Riverdale?
I kind of want to watch Riverdale only because I hear it gets so stupid.
And I want to know what happens.
I think Doki, like, watched the first episode and then the latest episode or last episode or something.
Terrace house?
Oh my god, my friend!
She loves Terrace house!
She loves, she loves.
And then what are the other ones?
Like, uh...
Um...
Blind love?
The one where there are people in the pods.
My friend tells me all about it.
Terrace house is the only one I actually watched.
Is it like...
I thought Terrace House was not as bad.
Or is it maybe the Terrace House that's like...
I don't know.
I actually have no idea.
I don't know anything.
You've taken your first steps towards becoming a legendary park manager.
Keep building and improving your park.
Your next star is waiting for you right after the next task!
Which is...
Oh!
Get more decoration points.
Oh my gosh.
That's so many points.
points we need okay all right we got this we're gonna put some bathrooms over here right next to the food and we're gonna put some bathrooms over here or something i don't know one right here and we're gonna is that decoration oh okay uh like this
Okay.
Palm tree!
It's so small!
Okay.
Decorating?
Ambience?
Oh, benches!
Okay, benches.
Huge.
Ugh.
You...
Wait, here, too?
Like so.
Cute.
Practical.
Okay.
We're already at 50?
58.
I think we got this.
I think we got this, boys.
Time to paint.
Yeah, we gotta paint.
I think umbrellas are our key to victory.
Umbrellas are the key to victory.
Oh.
Okay, nice.
Does this add...
Oh, wait.
I just realized I blocked our decoration there.
I'll get it.
Um, oh my gosh.
We're so close.
Okay.
We're so, so close.
Um.
We'll block the dumpster with a plant or something.
I don't know.
Uh.
these are pretty big how big how much are they oh they're only ten dollars some privacy here hold on wait we're gonna make like a really sexy area and
then oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah the woohoo bush oh i forgot to make another uh pool i think i have enough money
We can now make a big pool.
People might see you in the woohoo bush, but...
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
This should be enough.
Surely.
Oh no.
Never mind.
Okay, it didn't give us anything.
I think we're gonna have to...
Build as the park is open.
But we need another pool so we can increase our max capacity.
What else can I make?
More, more...
What am I talking about?
More umbrellas, more umbrellas.
While you're waiting.
While you're waiting in the shade.
While you're...
While you're shading.
While you're waiting.
Here and here.
Do I have any more money?
Oh gosh, I have enough money for one more umbrella.
Wait?
Wait!
You guys?
One more umbrella might do the trick.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I don't have enough money to buy anything.
Janitors!
Ah!
Wait, but that means...
Hiring!
I can hire one more person!
Oh!
Okay.
I can hire a janitor.
We can do this.
We can do this!
I have to sleep though.
Our ducky is becoming cleaner!
Wait, that's exciting!
Look at our place!
It's pretty cute!
No!
Oh.
Oh, sorry, Braylon.
Good morning.
I'm gonna go get some people in here.
All right.
Let's get the people.
Oh, we're coming in masses.
Are you into my park?
You?
Are you coming to the park?
Oh, sorry.
Are you guys coming to the park?
Yes.
Are you coming to the park?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yon.
Are you coming?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
There's a lineup.
Alright.
Minto's here.
Ready to spray you down.
I'm ready.
Did that guy come in here and immediately go to the...
I heard him go.
Hey.
Yeah.
Long line.
The people.
Oh wait, I'm not ready.
Did I stock my...
Okay, lemonade.
I didn't stock the hot dogs.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Oh, so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I just...
Sorry.
So sorry.
Add both.
Uh-huh.
Dozo!
Hello?
Add ketchup.
okay we're gonna add we're gonna buy um uh someone's drowning already oh oh georgina girl i don't know where the oh there it is you're lucky you got lucky girl wait we're drowning in this pool all the way in the freaking corner oops hold on kobe yeah you're welcome whoa i'm going to there was that one i wonder if i can oh the life sting rant life life ring stand i can't speak life ring stand okay
okay what are we doing we're gonna buy a janitor hire a janitor plan
please you guys know i can't speak okay janitor Marvin you're my man first janitor that I even saw okay and uh where is he wonder where he's at push cheaters from your park out of 10 oh wait we gotta be on the lookout for cheaters any cheaters about cheaters Cheaters,
cheaters, pumpkin.
Oops, sorry.
You're not a cheater.
Any pumpkin eaters?
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Hot dog.
Lemonade.
And ice.
Hot dog.
Add both.
Garbage.
Where's garbage?
Where's my janitor?
Hello.
Add both.
Did he just pay and then...
Did he just buy a burger?
Or a burger?
Wait, what did he buy?
Wait, did he just get and then...
I think I'm what?
I just served a cheater!
I did!
I'm going insane.
This game is making me actually insane.
This game is making me insane.
Hugo's drowning!
I got you, Hugo.
Uh, where's the floaty?
One moment, Hugo.
Don't drown on me.
Saved by the best!
Don't say rip, Hugo!
He lived, he lived!
Lemonade.
Uh, who did I just serve?
Oh.
Sorry.
What do you want?
Oh, nothing?
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Uh...
I don't know what to do with this.
Anyway, uh, add mustard.
Have 20 visitors in my park?
Oh my gosh!
What just happened?
I'm not quite sure.
Lemon?
Ice!
Doza!
Someone's drowning.
My park is dirty.
Priorities?
Who's drowning?
That was close.
Was it?
Did you just trip over the garbage?
Oh, I'm tripping.
I mean, so I'm currently dying from drowning.
I require immediate CPR.
open wide johnny johnny yes papa drowning in the pool no papa more drowning why are so many people drowning stop coming to the pool if you don't know how to swim
rosy's waiting for lemonade panicking on the diving board oh sorry i hit more than one Oh, this is garbage.
What are you?
Are you?
What are you doing?
Are you my janitor?
Are you Marvin the janitor?
Is my janitor bugged?
Oh my gosh.
Me too.
That's how I feel about my janitor being bugged.
I pay for you!
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
I
need you to work.
Marvin, I really need you to work.
I need you
to...
Marvin, I need you.
Okay, we're gonna hire a new janitor.
There are no more janitors!
Oh gosh!
Okay.
It's all me, everybody.
It's all me.
Hello, what can I help you with?
You want lemonade out of ice?
I got you?
Uh, add both.
Lemonade?
Oh, how much did you pay?
It was like $200!
Welcome.
I think- I think Bray- Bray-Lyn is gone right now.
Bray-Lyn, I really need- Bray-Lyn, please.
Is everybody bugged?
Bray-Lyn, please- I can't do this alone!
Please!
Yep.
Oh, no, not me!
I can't do this on my own.
Oh, please.
Oh,
please.
The NPCs are breaking.
I'm
just trying to clean.
Oh.
No!
Ah!
Rib Marvin's three children and wife.
My guy should have...
Should have unbugged himself!
It's a doggy dog world out there!
Hello?
Yes.
Hot dog ketchup.
There you go.
Sorry for the wait.
Thank you for being so patient with me.
Don't do it.
You could step anywhere else.
Raylan's back, right?
Oh, my god.
Hello.
Slide pass.
A teen.
Really?
Oh, okay.
I guess you could kind of look like a teen.
Wait, that's a man who's breaking the law.
Wait.
Why didn't I get...
Oh, you're just going anyway, okay.
Um, hello?
Oh, wait.
I didn't get that.
Wait, is he actually...
Oh.
Wait, maybe he's doing his job.
Oh, he is!
He's just...
He's telepathic!
Smelly?
...
Lemonade?
Add lemon?
Ice.
Catch up.
This is making me want a dog.
You know?
Lemon?
Ice.
This is making me want some dogs.
He's social distancing.
We love a considerate king.
What the?
Gavin is injured!
What did I do?
Gavin!
Oh, I think Gavin is dead.
Thank God.
The day is over.
One hot dog, please.
This one is for you, Minto.
Thank you.
Hide the body.
I received a fine.
I don't know what happened.
Surely there is something in the contracts.
Something in our contract.
Like, not contract.
Is that Gavin?
Oh, no, it's Kaysen.
Who the hell are you?
Surely there's some sort of waiver.
I think Braylon is broke, broke, man.
He can't do this.
I can't do this.
We can't do this anymore.
Yeah, there's gotta be some sort of waiver.
Oh.
hire a maintenance man yeah i think i think the game is i think the game is borked oh shoot wait hold on my meeting they were like mint is still playing water park simulator
they're like i just saw you on stream go oh shoot hold on and pause the game
Oh my gosh, I got so into this game.
Sorry.
I'm coming.
Where did the time go?
Anyways, everybody, thank you so much for a water park simulator.
This was a lot of fun.
I hope you had fun.
I will see you guys later.
Osamito!
Do I go, thank you!
Listening to your voice is keeping me sane.
You've been busy at work too!
Otsu!
Thanks for the stream, good luck at the meeting!
Thank you!
Have a meeting at the water park.
Easy peasy.
So true.
Okay!
Bye bye!
Otsumito!